[Music]
so
so many things and uh i'm opening a lot
of tabs
like i'm opening zoom i'm opening
another obs like to be honest i'm not
i'm not even using
the the same old layout uh like like
like i'm not using a green screen
because
we'll be using a webcam so right now
this is what we have
i'm kind of screen capturing right now
i'm the screen capturing everything and
making sure that
um everything goes well
so so so yeah let's calm down
i have my manager with me my manager is
being so nice right now my mother says
like
calm down ali it's okay take your time
we also have connor too i i heard
connor's watching
and and thank you so much everyone for
coming yes i am
wait am i on chess tv oh wait am i on
test tv
is this me wait i don't know if you guys
can see it just a minute
i'm on test tv
hello they're streaming my stream this
is awesome
i like this hello everyone i am the
zombie idol that everyone adores
man this is cool this is my first ever
um what is it called
it's my first ever tournament ever like
ever
ever i'm
i'm relatively new to chess like i know
how the pieces work
but very very new to it you know
um
uh what else should i say
i i already took a shower i ate
breakfast
it was like getting ready for school but
much more intense
okay got it manager son thank you i
can't reply to you because i'm afraid if
i i do that you can see that oh oh i
can't actually reply
i didn't that's kind
lots of blenders lots of blenders and
we're not we haven't even started we
haven't even started everyone
and we already have a lot of blenders
not
not very good um
ollie this is too early i i know it is
but
uh um what can we do right
wait how's that on check night only one
move and
[Music]
let's go
let's go oh that feels so good
let me just make sure of this
easy winning
let's go let's go oh
mate is on the board the maid is on the
board yeah i think she hasn't gone for
the trip
just to go for the tricks she's gonna
move this here but then i just take it
with the this if i move up here is that
checkmate wow
i think that might be and let's watch
him finish this thing yes
yeah 23 seconds remaining i got it
uh yeah
oh you know what i want to do
i wanted to no
no no no
[Music]
oh no luckily this game
i haven't so i keep thinking my camera's
over there
this game i haven't haven't took royally
so
see that i see that
i see that ah oh this is the training
training
oh okay like last game was fond dude he
made me think
he made my monkey brain have to think
bro
that was i was damn he brought the
monkey brain out of the stone age
watch the commentators be listening in
on this part we are not listening in on
this part
not at all what are you gonna do john i
don't know what are you gonna do what
did i miss what i miss
what i've missed oh we can just take my
rook i'm an idiot
i'm an idiot i'm throwing
i forgot that his rook could attack my
rook
the same way my rook could attack his
i forgot i forgot that his rook
could attack my rook the same way that
he can i'll take it
i'll take it but i no wait a second i
didn't forget that
no he still took my rooks wait no
i'm actually losing my pawn breaks and
what a pawn break is is where you push a
pawn to try to
change the pawn oh
oh my gosh no
oh wow and you you see
oh
[Music]
oh i'm out i'm out guys that was great
thanks
[Music]
he's setting it up yep he's setting up
the ladder checkmate the king only has
one
oh thank god and he
he has it he has it oh my god that was
so
stressful that was so stressful
oh my god i said to my chat i was like
watch this russia just going to do all
of these moves
and i i said that he did them and he did
them yeah
okay jojo jack made
one second come on come on
oh my god
come on come on come on
game game on
game on so that's history jake has never
beaten conor until now
conor the heavy favorite to win
tournament arc is now down one nothing
it's win or go home for sea dog
i can't believe that i can't believe it
repeats with the knight to c5 with the
draw
oh
i don't know if he knows three group
repetition if black plays king c7 it's a
draw
oh no don't play king c7 please
oh by repetition
what
oh my god what how is that a drool by
repetition
oh my god
this is it we are here tournament arc
2 is finally underway and uh
i'm here of course with my host japanese
tutor
uh jt what's going on man are you
excited for this
i'm um the last one was amazing and with
this lineup i think it's gonna
be even better i just can't wait for the
first
start i'm getting jitters is that normal
[Laughter]
oh my god yeah i'm so i'm so so so ready
for this
uh welcome everybody uh for
wherever you're watching whether it's
twitch youtube twitter
facebook um
maybe spacex is broadcasting this from
the moon i'm not sure
but it is finally time the wait is over
uh we've uh it's taken us just shy maybe
like a month shy of a year
uh to finally bring tournament arc 2 to
life
we've got some amazing players we've
brought back uh some of the
the names from uh the first season
including the champion gigguk the
runner-up
sea dog uh rustage who made it to the
third place match and
i and then of course some amazing
newcomers v tubers
and we did a twist this time we brought
some fighting game community players
what'd you think about that when i first
pitched it uh jt
i love the idea i used to be a fighting
game player myself i used to go to
fighting game tournaments actually
uh when i took a break from chess and i
used to play ultimate more versus capcom
a little bit of a blaze blue so i'm
really excited to see how these players
uh play okay okay and you've been
coaching as well
some of the players inc including those
representing the fighting game community
um do you feel like in some of those
coaching sessions
they've found like parallels between
uh what it's like to compete at the
highest levels in fighting games and
and uh developing chess kill
yeah definitely uh there's a parallel
between chess and fighting games i
believe that just chess is a 2d
bass fighting game and so if you find
all the correct options
that you will be a good chess player
well i mean there's only one way to
really find out if that is the case and
that's
in the games it's themselves uh so i
want to explain the format for
uh those of you at home who haven't had
a chance to catch up on
what this is all about so tournament arc
is a double elimination bracket
comprise the best of three matches so
the first player to make it to two
points
wins their pairing uh and the winners of
those pairings move on to the winners
side
of the bracket the losers of these first
round
games will move to the redemption arc
side where they can climb their way back
to
face the winner of the winner's side in
a grand final
for the championship uh the prizes
we've actually doubled since tournament
arc one
ten thousand dollar prize pool divided
uh four thousand dollars for the
champion
of this event determined on the final
day on the 25th
second place not bad 2 500 bucks for
their effort
making their their way all the way back
from that redemption arc
third place 1500 fourth place 800 and
all the players from fifth place to
eighth place will receive
300 so everybody gets a little something
for participating
the time control of these games will be
10 minutes on each player's clock 10 and
and they will gain five seconds for
every move they make we call that
increment
in chess uh and if for whatever reason
let's say we get
a tied match where at the end of these
three
games they're one and a half one and a
half right well what do we do
a tie break and it's going to be a fast
tie break of just
three minute time control with no
increment
so maybe i don't know you think we get
into tie breaks we're gonna see some
people trying to dirty flag each other
make the other person
run out of time
um that's definitely going to happen
if we get to these those are going to be
the hypest rounds and i just can't wait
every game is so important and in the
tie breaks it's going to be
so short and i suggest some flagging
it's going to be a bit dirty but you
know i just suggest that the players go
for flagging
and for quick moves it's going to be
exciting no matter what and
let's talk about the participants really
quick i want to mention again
sea dog va gigga rustage all returning
from
tournament ark season one but then we
have some new representatives from both
the anime
community and the fighting game
community tech tone uh
gentian impact streamer and
self-proclaimed weeb game player
uh crazy ollie a v tuber
from uh hollow live indonesia an amazing
amazing content creator uh kind of
sticks out for a lot of people
as uh we've seen some people on twitter
say it's almost like a custom character
in a cut scene at a video game where you
go absolutely crazy with the character
design
standing here amongst all these other
players uh and then we have
representatives from the fighting game
community esam and
kizzy k uh representing
uh panda global esports
uh organization and then say jam uh
amazing fighting game commentator for
over a decade
content creator and uh and just great
ambassador of the fighting games at
large
um we'll talk a little bit more about
the participants as we get close to the
games but i also want to
just sort of uh show everybody a
visualization of what we mean about
these two arcs so
winners will move on to what you see
above sort of indicated in blue as the
winners bracket
and those people will actually have less
matches to worry about
on their way to grand final uh losers
from these
four first round matches however will
drop
into the what we're calling the
redemption arc uh and they'll have to
face uh
many more opponents if they are going to
make their way all the way back
not only win the redemption bracket but
then face
the winningest player uh in the event
to ultimately be crowned tournament arc
champion uh what do you think about this
uh jt
bringing this double elimination format
uh which we did not have last time
in tournament arc one well i love this
double elimination bracket
just like every fighting game tournament
and i think this is a great place to use
it because we do have some fighting game
players here so
i'm excited to see how this turns out
and you know you can lose the first
round and come back and win the whole
thing
which is amazing yeah i absolutely love
that and obviously we've got a lot of
people who are fans of tournament one
and watch the amazing final between
gigguk and sea dog va
where sea dog lost in a three move
repetition draw
which then uh because of a two game mini
match uh
crowned giga the winner and we just
decided you know what
let's go ahead and see if conor can get
revenge
right off the bat in the first round and
that match will actually start tomorrow
but we've got two matches that are going
to start right now beginning with
kizzy k versus crazy ollie we are going
to take a short break
we'll even take a peek at uh at ali
getting ready
and settling uh whatever nerves there
might be before the first game and when
we return
tournament arc 2 begins so stick around
and we'll be back in just a few moments
dangerous
[Music]
are you nervous very nervous tournament
arc 2 is live now with crazy ollie
versus kizzykontest.com
oh my god i can't believe that crazy is
fighting kizzy okay
yeah i i i watch the oh i'm going to
turn off the chat a little
okay so the the live chat is now off i'm
very sorry everyone
60 seconds
is the live chat off is it off
is it off yet it should be off right
okay the live chat is officially off
so now you guys can't send in um
comments anymore sorry
sorry
should yes play
be counting carefully consider all your
options you have time right
all right this breeze will be fine
that that's a funny thing to tell a
zombie nope the game will automatically
start okay the game will automatically
start
man man it's so weird to not to
to to like not see
like it's it's weird to not be able to
see the live chat like i can still see
the live chat i can still see the live
chat that you guys sent me so i'm just
going to read those
everyone's saying good luck oh
i'm going to cry become think carefully
consider all your options all you come
home let's go we're here for y'all good
luck time to
go well we are still here just remember
that then good luck ollie got this guy
to keep that confidence right
this week he'll be fine let's drink a
little oh my god it feels like middle
school again
but the thing about middle school is
that you're not being
watched by thousands of people
i used to join lots of competitions too
back in the day like like i used to
can't really specify what competition
that i won
but there was a lot of competitions yeah
i need to bring myself down a little bit
this should be okay okay um
remember anna's words check capture
attack
check capture attack kizzy please go
easy on me
please don't grapple my king
don't annihilate my pegasus
blink
we could hang out kizzy
um yeah
good game
yeah there's going to be um a slight
delay
so let's just namaste a little bit let's
breathe in
breathe out breathe in breathe out
yeah it feels a bit weird i'm just going
to to read the chats how you guys sent
me good luck
make y'all go proud ollie i will
[Music]
you know whatever floats your boat or
whatever we got to do for charity right
we sometimes sacrifices must be made
sometimes i gotta use my body as a
shield
ah
stressed out dog
why couldn't i be like a why couldn't i
be like a monster hunter player bro this
was like dane was this is why as i dang
dodge all this why couldn't i be a
monster hunter player
i could have been a monster hunter
player i could have been like eight like
uh what is that um what game i got
discontinued freaking titanfall
i could have been a titanfall player i
could have been like halo 3.
all right it is time went offline for a
second apologies to everybody who was
confused about that but we are back and
we are ready to go
the games are gonna start right now
with kizzy k with the white pieces here
we go
it's time
let's see i'm excited i want to see the
opening
i i hope that they prepped i know that
they were playing a lot of chess
and i think it's going to be it's going
to be shown in their opening choices
right
um i wonder what opening shows they're
going to play are they going to
e4 d4 c4 knight f3 knight c3
g4 the grub
we shall see we shall see
games are actually underway jt if you
want to lead us through the chess
they have made their opening moves here
we go
round one of tournament arc 2 begins
all right let's go right there and uh
we're going to go and we're going to
head back into d4
d466 e5
whoa okay it's kind of spicy
like takes e5 and we are in the live
stream so let's go ahead bishop f4 being
played
f6 and f6 is
i i don't like the move f6 in the
opening because
we might have some ideas of bishop
captures on e5
and then queen h5 and it gets kind of
dicey
yeah and i hear all the time that uh
it's it's not really
a good idea to necessarily move the f
pawn
early on right right right so
i almost want to consider the f pawn of
poison pawn in the opening um ooh
this oh wow
we might see some fireworks here okay um
because he's developing his pieces but
um the knight going to h6 is a very bad
indication because
at least bishop captured a6 it ruins the
pawns and the f-pawn's very weak
and the reason we don't want to move the
f-pawn is because that is the weakest
pawn
right it's the only upon us that only
defended by the king
well it looks like his he did not
necessarily
either consider or go with the uh the
trade of the knight on h6 which would
double all these pawns make it uh
unappealing to castle in that direction
and now he's thinking right what do you
do is he maybe thinking
do i back up or do i move back towards
okay
moves back towards center i like it i
like it
the idea maybe going back to b3
um maybe you can run some
castling yeah okay aggressive she says
okay let's go
i'm gonna push in right away make you
make you move that bishop a bunch of
times in fact
they're not bishops jt i don't know if
you know this
according to crazy ollie they are the
marquee
the more key i see
yes and she didn't develop a knight on
h6
she developed a pegasus
this is important
this is this is important insight into
into ollie's uh
all these world of chess effect maybe
with uh some more insight is needed you
want to
take a look and a listen at ollie's
stream right now and see what she's
thinking
let's do it let's do it let's take a
peek
yet so i think
we're going to attack a little bit more
let's try sneaking but if i go here then
the
then i'll get eaten by this
okay ollie what's the plan i don't know
there's so many people watching you
should we just move the pond
i mean this side is already on defense
mode so we might as well attack
i think i don't know how it works i'm
very sorry
you guys are probably cringing at me
right now
i think she's doing okay well what
scares me if this i think she said
you know it scares me a lot please
please don't eat my pond that's
something that i don't want to happen
and i gotta be careful because there's a
queen so if this pond goes away
i gotta make sure that i eat the queen
like we can have an exchange i don't
mind the next change at all
like like ah see that happens
okay deciding what to do this is not bad
see what she decides to do can i can i
wha what capture
options do i have
i like how she's looking at all her
pieces i see what you did there
i see what you did there but i mean if
you eat this
if you eat this then uh then i'll eat
the queen
oh man this is intense what do i do
let's try pinning actually
the pin that's just like if nothing else
works the painting's on court
hey i don't hate it you know what else i
i don't hate actually is that the chat
on twitch has voted they did a poll
before the game started to see what does
the chat think who's going to win ollie
or kissy and there's actually 48
percent for ollie and 52 kizzy so the
chat
also feels like this is a pretty close
match and i'm gonna have to agree with
them
let's also spend a little bit of time
looking in on kizzy as well
yeah i definitely wonder how he's
thinking about the position community
too
giving up a little bit of the initiative
but i do
like the development i do like before
thinking maybe he wants to play bishop
takes on h6 but he's got to be careful
about moving his own knight now
and putting his own queen in the line of
fire of that bishop
also looking at his other pieces
thinking about options maybe even a long
castle here
oh you called it
and i think that the opening moves go
ahead
the opening moves um
making it a really really good opening
but what happens in the middle game
is what's important because we make one
mistake looking for
freaking
pistols that's going to get me killed at
smg's it's not going to help oh no
bro oh no
and we should also note the time
decision you know
they're only at 7-30 seconds but they're
both around the same time so
they're both taking about the same
amount of time to make decent moves
yeah and the other thing that that i
just took away from
that little listen in that we got with
kizzy is that
he's kind of feeling the pressure right
if we look at the eval bar we can see
that you know the engines kind of say
white is doing great right here but i
think also
your mentality comes into play too and
your nerves and it seems like kizzy is
i don't know maybe he's seeing threats
that aren't that don't have as much
teeth
necessarily objectively but but it maybe
doesn't matter right if
if ali continues to put on the pressure
it's gonna affect
the decisions because he makes here
yeah the other thing about um what is
what a beginner
starts to calculate is they try to see
everything
and there's an expression that
the beginner sees 10 000 things
um and thousand ways to do something and
ten thousand options but the expert
only sees one way right so we're we're
kind of trained to kind of like
some people in the chat might be like
really really strong and you're like
wait there's only one way to continue
here but remember they are looking at
all the pieces
the a pawn the b pawn the c pawn the
bishop on b3 the knight on c3
they're not used to you know these plans
yet
so we have to tell them slack for
finding reasonable moves
like these are pretty good moves oh
what about g4 for white right now
hitting the knight
and the bishop
this is this don't get tasty
i mean is there a way to escape that
tactic in this position
if you're black
i i don't i don't see a way it's
oh and he misses it yeah but you have to
see it you have to see it yeah
i mean you know it looks like a natural
developing move though right get your
knight into the game
um and and i i appreciate that right
if if you're gonna miss something at
least miss it in a way that's principled
right but you know what he's getting all
of his pieces active
yeah right it's a good sign bishop one
four
yep knight on e2 knight on c3 maybe his
record is going to come to e1
right and you don't see a tactic you
might see it later
but at least all of your pieces are
developed and we know that
tactics flow from good positions and
ollie's doing the same look at all these
pieces i mean they're like
talk about activity she's gotten all the
minor pieces out they're all doing work
in different ways
it's only a mistake if your opponent
sees it right yeah
that's a beginner mantra
[Laughter]
well let's take a look another listen in
fact we have kind of a cool view where
we could see
both streams at the same time but we'll
bring up just one audio at a time for
you maybe not crazy we'll start with
crazy ollie actually in a way we are
starting off crazy i have no idea what
i'm doing
[Laughter]
[Music]
i really hate this pawn right now this
pawn right here
i hate it so much because i could do so
many things if this pond was not here
i want to get rid of it
my my objective right now is either i
get the queen by tricking it
by trapping it
oh moving the queen back
ah that's one thing
what i want to do right now is that i
want to get my queen out
how do we do that how do we get our
queen out
okay okay there's a potential checkmate
but we have to get rid of this guy
that knight on d6 looks pretty tasty for
white
maybe there's some kind of way to remove
the defender what do you think i know
yeah there's uh there are a lot of good
moves in this position
um but it was nice from i wonder if she
sees it
that it's check
because it's a discovered attack right
maybe she's just focusing on the pawn
and the bishop i wonder
if she's gonna find it maybe you could
show that on the board for the audience
so we can kind of see a potential
sequence here
right so right here right
the uh the bishop is attacking oh there
we go
oh that takes immediately
and the knight can't take him
but the bishop can and then the
the other bishop can right so maybe i
don't know i would've took with the
bishop but oh the king just moves
okay yeah this is tricky actually
this might be okay for one
bishop takes on d6 and bishop takes one
two six oh there's a promotion
oh boy a little early kizzy
yeah a little early
let's take a look and see how he feels
about his
land so far i never got this far
oh no
[Laughter]
i never got this far okay okay okay
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay okay okay okay
okay okay
oh my god bro
why bro
okay and this is not totally bad you
know i mean the night's
on the back rank and maybe gonna come
back maybe it's a c4 oh
bishop going back to g6
now looking at this threat of maybe some
potentially something on the king side
right where you can get something on the
c file
maybe a rock to go on the t pile and
moving kind of fast
back in the game would be good
maybe sometimes we're threatening the b
pawn
right with the two knights and be kind
of careful because there
still is a pin
and you know what i'm impressed by as i
look at the clocks is it feels like
they're both
playing fairly patiently
okay knight takes queen can't take
because then the knight will also take
right
attack twice and defend it only once
but maybe there's tactics to trade off
the bishop for the night on c3 and then
queen takes
the night on beef all right i mean you
can you can also have like queen takes
b5 right
oh true right because after knight takes
all right
and then the knight would then the take
takes and then we just take back and
it's just a trade
that's kind of nice nice idea but i
don't know if you need to go for that
right now
i like working the pin you know i'm a
big proponent of pp on the ppp right put
pressure on the pin piece
okay all right ollie continues to bring
the pressure i
i'm really impressed with the fact that
uh ali has
just like really brought an attack and
because he seems uh
mostly on the back foot here as white
yeah i wonder what's going to happen
here um i would really love to listen to
what ali
is thinking right now because let's do
it
i want i really want to get to the king
how do we get to the king
you want to have an exchange i don't
want to have an exchange we're already
at the same score what do you want to do
you don't have you don't have a bright
future here talking about i mean i could
just
back up with my queen my queen can't
back up anyone my queen is the best
what do we do i really don't know what
do we do
um
i really love that she's talking to her
piece hey what do you want to do where
do you want to go it's something that i
always tell my students
i don't want to do a blunder
talking about her pieces happy future
and and i kind of use that similar term
of like where's the future for my pieces
man that took me a whole minute you know
some moves like knight c6
that took me a whole minute you know
trying to trade off their good pieces
and knight to c6 would actually
play here so let's just like that and
then it would be attacking
these two pieces so i wonder
if they're going to find that or not um
there are a lot of
moves yeah there's still a minefield and
you have to navigate through it because
we also have this idea
and ollie might have this idea later of
taking with this
exposing this file
wow this is this is actually an awesome
first game
yeah it's a lot of back and forth right
like white was winning black was winning
and now it's even right like is this the
uh
anime battle that uh we've never seen
before like i might have to
i'm not taking another t for this um
[Music]
yeah this is great so i i have a
question for you if you play that nice
c6 move forking the queen and the bishop
then is the is black's queen forced to
c5
to be able to still recapture are there
tactics after that
does the queen have other options like
it seems
really dicey
yeah i think lucy five right it would be
a great move there oh and not taking on
f5 okay i see
not letting them take first that might
be a very um
it's a bold decision and it
opens up the g file remember um they're
on an exchange
i take this okay wow what again i do
like the activity
i like black activity here
and what's interesting if you just do a
count of the material real quick
right uh white is down a rook but has an
extra piece for it and
i don't necessarily want to judge that
as is better or worse
for either player right now
do you right i
i don't know it's it's still dicey it's
still pretty dicey
um i wouldn't i want to say that one
person has the university although i do
like black's activity in black pieces
so i might have to just
give it to back here
i mean as we see as we've seen this is
anybody's game
oh am i hanging on e2 will they see it
green knight on e2 but those are kind of
sometimes hard to see
because you feel like you're so deep in
into their house that it seems a little
scary right
right right right and maybe also white
house
but then you know queen d8 check
oh well i mean then it was back right
the rook on uh on the f5 can just go
back maybe
right defended by the bishop
narrowly escape being checkmated
i i think we need to get all of our
pieces back to safety i would play
moves like knight c3 or this is going to
be kind of rough here
um there is a checkmate here there is a
checkmate fret
since the queen does not control the
square anymore
we had a rook here
to take followed by queensland
still available right if the knight on
g3
does i think we have to play something
like bishop d2 right we have to play
something like this
let's see let's see our ordinary four
makes a lot of sense here
backwards bishop moves are also
something that uh that are difficult to
see right we always kind of think we
want to move our pieces forward we want
to
attack we want to get over there into
their house but
these sort of retreating moves can be uh
obviously
you know can save you a game if you can
see them
we can see that this is probably one of
the first times a piece has moved past
her
right with knight to a4 so they've only
been playing on their half
for most of the game oh now it's still
available yeah let's see let's see
rookie he won and she found it wow
and let's listen in here can we listen
yeah
[Laughter]
ah
wow ollie takes home
game one as black this is a match
dude this is amazing kizzy put up a
great fight
and i think i you know it could go
either way still in the second game but
like
what a confidence boost right
oh yeah oh man like just winning the
first game
and just knowing that you have the upper
hand and that you're not
like you can actually win it's a huge
confidence boost so hopefully kizzy can
you know come back and say okay well i'm
ready to fight too and i'm ready to take
the action back to you
um but a great game for both players
right we had a lot of action white was
winning black was running white was
landing
winning it was equal that white was
winning the black was winning right so
um let's
it's going to be a it's going to be a
fun match it's going to be
this is going to be a good one and uh
we're going to give the players a break
we're gonna take a break ourselves
come back and see game two uh this
is uh kizzy's gotta stay in this maybe
get a win even if you draw the second
game you get white again you try again
but
uh we'll see how it goes we'll be back
in just a few moments with game two
stick around
[Laughter]
thank you for believing me everyone
those puzzles really did miracles
um we still have one more hand literally
one more round i gotta win them
i i gotta turn off the chat again real
soon
wait my heart doki doki
one more game we haven't won yet
like if you know would be funny it'd be
it it'd be really cool if casey actually
got me a checkmate like if kissy didn't
get checkmate
like it'd be cool if he did me a
checkmate and then on the next round
we'd have a draw and then we actually
have to do a deuce
that'd be kind of cool relax
let's go analyze the game yes
let's go lucky close good job let's go
congrats ollie thank you everyone
kizzy will be on work kizzy will be more
on guard from now on oh that
oh that is a big spoiler manager son
thank you for telling me
oh this is going to be hard because
cause kizzy is going to see through my
my little slick tricks is going to be
very very hard
kizzy i'm sorry but can we play apex now
kissy up for a game of apex
because he want to play apex now like
like we don't have to do chess anymore
we can just
chill and apex that'd be nice
he'll be more defensive probably yeah
no brain
a draw will make your brain tired ollie
not really it's going to be fun it's
going to be fun to be honest draws will
only excite me more oh
exciting
okay okay i gotta turn off the chat now
i'm very sorry everyone
what's up thank you so much everyone
thank you for all thank you for all of
the congratulations
thank you i'll try my best
on the next one since kizzy will be on
since kitty will be more defensive
then i'll be more defensive too that's
the plan
like it'll be defense versus defense i
think
i can't let him grapple my king
how long did that take that that that
took like 20 minutes something right
20 something ish
you know what yeah let's do let's just
do apex again can we like go in apex
right now three
and uh wow ollie wins
game one with almost an extra minute on
the clock as well
and already kind of uh uh
predicting that both players might play
a little bit more defensively now but
who
is crazy ollie she is a v
tuber representing hololive
indonesia she speaks three languages i
don't know if you knew that jt
indonesian japanese english and she even
said
she speaks them during her stream all at
the same time
wait she transitions through three
languages that's crazy
yeah that's amazing it's awesome the
audience you guys should definitely
check out
crazy ollie's youtube channel if you
have not yet she even does math lessons
as well
and who knows maybe that's maybe that's
helping her a bit with
uh with her chest skills calculating and
thinking about exchanges
and uh but she is up against
a formidable opponent in terms of his
fighting game prowess
kizzy k is uh one of
two representatives uh for panda global
and uh known for games like guilty gear
dragon ball fighters
uh we talked a little bit about it
earlier but the fighting game competitor
mentality has
actually translated fairly well in the
coaching sessions and and i think we are
seeing that on the board
uh so what do you think jt game two
olly up one point this is a best of
three
so someone has to get to two points
before they've
uh finished out their match and that
means you know because he can still win
a game maybe even draw game and go in
tie breaks
or just win two in a row and turn the
whole thing around
i don't know the way kissy was playing
his opening he had
really solid ideas right like get get
castles develop the pieces get pieces of
good squares
look for your opponent's threats i i
think because he was doing everything
right
and ollie was struggling a bit in the
opening
but where ali really shined was her
middle game and her idea she was
saying hey let's move my queen to good
squares i need to get you know this pin
in i need to attack king how do i get my
pieces over there
so the planning from ollie was really
really good so i'm
wondering how that's going to translate
because they're switching colors right
and sometimes for beginners it's easier
to play black because
white makes you know the first moves
and they set the tone and they say the
pace of the game so i really wonder how
that's going to translate into
our next game well kizzy with the black
pieces in game two and uh
as we get the next game underway it's
gonna start just any moment uh we
should maybe take a listen in and see
how cuz he feels about his performance
in that first game
oh my god my god
oh my god bro i just wanna
i wanna know man what did i do to you
ollie i just wanna play fighting games
i just want to play fighting games ollie
oh wait all these little piece here
okay okay okay
what do you think so far jt what's going
on on the board
and i was just talking about because
these openings and
here we are in full version of the
opening he has an opening advantage and
he plays
king to e7 delayed bonk cloud
whoa you've been watching it
wow we called it this is gonna get
exciting and i don't know
what what what what is going on here
this is literally a bonk block and
i think honestly the position is not
that bad if we are able to play c6 king
d7 king c7 i think our king is perfectly
placed
um kind of a reroute almost even maybe a
castle by hand get the rook out of there
first and then dig back
in but wow he said he want to play
fighting games like this is gonna be a
fighting game for sure
in fact chess may be one of the oldest
fighting games oh what
bro it is getting crazy here
i understand why her name is crazy ollie
whoa neither player can castle now yes
absolutely whoa whoa whoa what is going
on
we lost the queen
man we lost our waifu
uh we should definitely castle here i
think
i'm going to go defensive
patrol defense classical variation
he he has six points ahead of me that's
not good
now my my main objective is either to
get
queen two or
check the king
there's actually a potential tactic
here after d3
if ollie sees it could follow up maybe
with
bishop g5 but then onto f6 and it
actually
doesn't have as much teeth as i thought
it did
well i mean the same idea holds true if
if cause you decided to move that pawn
to f5 right
and then that that dd move would have
been really good because you're baiting
the take right so like let's say it
right in this position if they played
like five
and you can bait them by playing d3 and
if they ever do take
then we have the line that you were
talking about
yeah and then ollie can bring the
material
okay okay and actually it looks like she
has played d3
a little late for the tactics we
discussed but still not bad
right not bad at all
so i think that chat might have it right
here i think uh
factor is that indeed the bon cloud
opening boats has
gambit accepted is the fire opening
[Laughter]
probably the two craziest
tactics in chess and we got him in one
game this is going to be fantastic
and kissy uh may bring us uh
into a third game to determine the
winner of this pairing
but you got to play it right and we
we are also looking at the piece
development by alden
ollie is doing well the light squared
bishop on e2 is not doing so hot
but if we can get our rooks maybe to f1
uh maybe double up the rooks on the f5
try to get some play
you know this is not over yet kenzie k
still has to find the right moves to
steal the deal
and i know that ollie's not just gonna
give up the game
and knight a6 might look strange but i
kind of feel like it's all right i mean
you can now bring it back into the game
with nice e5
and get back into the center start
pushing putting pressure on the center
pawns
and i think moves um even like knight
c796 might
play a decent role um
it smells very interesting i don't
completely get it
maybe she's thinking she can prevent the
knight from developing to c5 but the
problem is when you're down material
you don't want to trade your remain your
remaining pieces you need those
right there's a there's a really good
saying that when you're down
material you want to trade pawns not
pieces
if you trade pieces it'll make your
opponent's life easier
so when you're up material you want to
trade pieces when you're commenting you
want to trade pawns
okay well dizzy definitely loves to
listen to what
izzy yeah yeah i was about to say
because he's in a decent position now
and maybe we'll get some insight looking
in
to see how he plans to take advantage of
this
now remember if i'm not mistaken both
players have moved their kings so
because he can't castle here even though
it looks like
you know the the starting position for
those two pieces
right
right they can castle king
king you're gonna have to learn how to
you don't have to learn how to learn how
learn how to catch some hands bro
like you might have to be fighting with
these guys dude
we did not do that
can i do it
oh okay so he he eyed the
pawn on b2 but noticed that the knight
defends it so
very nice good awareness
okay ops uh ali ops for getting a
rook to the open file there which is
good
controlling this semi open file
i feel like this is the part of the game
where ollie kind of shines because
it's that planning aspect right we're
out of the opening our pieces are
already out
now what
what are we going to do bishop p7 the
retreating movement
we haven't developed any pieces yet
would love to see some uh
maybe a king you know king uh d7 kings
seven ruler out and get uh getting the
pieces on the
e and f5 or the heavenses right so
an idea say oh and stopping kd7 hey my
pieces are going to be active
what a good move she's definitely
trying to limit activity maybe she is
aware of the material disadvantage and
saying okay well
if i can at least make it difficult for
you to develop that rook
then it's almost like you don't have a
rook
right right i think one of the plans
here and if i'm just going to make a
move here it's going to be knight c7
maybe 96
right let's say like something like c3
or actually maybe not c3 but
any move uh let's say king here
and just try to control some some
squares and you know pushing
we might be able to counter push make
some weaknesses and even if we
upon we're up so much material that we
can afford to give it up sometimes
we have to also pay attention to moves
like queen a5
uh and getting some access to the fifth
rank as well as uh hitting the knight
and we also have to get these two rooks
into play we had to get
the a-rook and the e-h-rook into play
you know if we don't have these pieces
playing then
we're down material yeah and maybe
that's time
if gizzy can open up the position then
there's more options for those pieces on
the back rank to do something and here
we go okay d5
nice good move good move
and look at the clock actually this is
interesting two and a half extra minutes
for ollie here
who's been moving relatively quickly
making
natural looking moves and safe moves uh
it's easy to make a move quickly if it's
a response
uh to something that you're doing rather
than necessarily
a plan of its own and she's playing
patiently which
and and kizzy on the on the other hand
um
is spending a lot of time trying to
figure out what's next
we have a tactic here um that could
potentially open things up
and it starts off with the skewer
here so let's go back and move it starts
off with this skewer
right hitting this and so you just don't
want to lose a peach right so
the rook has to come back and then
something like this right where we're
taking here
wow and the pawn on because we can't
take it
because it's pinned and this sequence
looks
really really nice or black
so let's go back and see what they did
in the game i think i saw knight b4
right before this
aggressive g5 okay
is he starting to to think about
attacking at this point
and maybe that move also helps with you
know
bishop or rook to g8 and then down
and then out getting that rook finally
into the game
well i think we might see maybe even h5
after this right
h5 g4 bishop to g5
that might be a consideration right take
this bishop out
play g4 right because the bishop is most
likely going to go to f5 and if it goes
to
h3 and i'll just put that on the board
for everyone
if it goes to h3 we're going to
get some material with a double attack
yeah
interesting most likely
it's going to go here and then after g4
moving
then we get to trade pieces
yep pin to the king so it it is a very
forceful move
and a trade is good for kizzy let's see
what
kizzy is seeing because it looks like
he's finally figuring out how to put
ollie on the back foot
so
interesting how he selects a piece to
see those little dots that kind of tell
you okay where are the potential moves
for that piece
and then consider with that with that
visualization
the value or or not of making that move
and there's your h5
yeah and a volleyback
bishop h3 would not be so hot
yeah you have to play oh and um
let's see let's see what's going to
happen here
i want to see ollie's response honestly
hopefully he sees g4 i i really don't
know what to do really
i don't know an important moment for
kizzy but look at the clock
serious time trouble this time six and a
half to two and a half
if i move this here then i'll be eaten
i don't have my queen i blundered i
blundered so bad when i lost my queen
ah now he's going to take either my rook
or my marquis
i hate him i hate him so much
how about we play it how do we how are
we going to play this
he's going to take either one of them
i want to check is there literally no
check please don't do it
oh don't do it i don't do
it oh don't do it
oh don't do it
we're saving our rook because our rook
is worth so many points
oh don't do it
oh my god okay um
he did it ollie he did it your marquee
is
toast
and chess sometimes one mistake but gets
another mistake
and here knight c5 uh oh i think you're
in
a little bit of trouble
giving kizzy more material but with less
than two minutes on the clock
kizzy has to like deal with a lot of
material and then still find checkmate
here
oh yeah i hope hopefully he knows some
of the basic checkmates because
that might come into play very very soon
wow
it's very bold of uh
kids he's just going in yeah yeah and
how do you continue as black here
i really like like after c2
but um bishop capture c5 was my first
choice
they should capture c5 and after bishop
captures
let me capture here um a move ago i
honestly think that was the best move
because you can't really do anything you
almost force a tick because this
piece is done and if you play something
let's say like this try to pin the uh
the knight to the queen then we could
just move the queen somewhere
anywhere and get into position
right even even moves like a3 are decent
because just
back and uh we're good to go another
consideration might be
to say hey well i can try to get a whole
bunch of material and an attack on your
king
and sacrifice my knight because i'm so
far ahead
i think it's so weak that i can do this
and i have the luxury to do this right
so
uh that that would be a play here but
you have to find that with uh a lot of
time and let's actually go through what
happened
because there's there was some action
that happened
so after the take 1956 bishop went back
g1 and then he was able to take the
knight at the rook
on a1 with his knight wow for free
but you know i wanted to ask you about
that so do you feel like in in a sense
you can find yourself or kizzy in that
situation find himself with almost too
many
options and then just having to choose
one consumes
time on your clock yeah um
the thing that i say is if you find a
winning line
you're down on time just go for the
you don't have to find the best line if
you find a line that is winning and
you're like that's a 8 and five but you
find them made it and
or there's a made in three but you might
you find oh
you know you in two pieces and you're
still winning the game but you just
don't see them made of three sometimes
it's just better to go for that
that line found um
you know you can look after the game and
say oh man i miss something but it's
better to win a winning game than to
lose on time
when you're winning
this is uh this is this is crazy
minute and a half and uh kizzy may not
be able to convert
a winning position and uh
allows ollie to move on to the winners
bracket
i think this is this is winning enough
because they only have a rook left ollie
oh
my god okay there's checkmate and two
checkpoints
can he find it
yes come on
see let's see if you can find it
but he only has a minute left so here i
would just start making moves
yeah even if you don't see it i mean
they can't take the night because of
queen c1
it's a you know it's a really good
position
finding that
oh why did i do that i think he sees
it now but it's definitely um
less than a minute
it was just ticking down i'm getting
kind of worried for him
he sees the potential for a checkmate
she's trying to work it out
touch the rook for a moment thinking
okay maybe the night is lost but i can
bring the rook in
and do something
oh my god bro i don't have much time bro
i panicked
[Music]
i mean if we can just get the queen in
and then get some rocks in as well we
might be in good shape but we can
actually save our night now
okay she's allowed a way out and a
potential
attack
okay let's see hopefully she doesn't
play rookie one
um check oh she does
and kissy doesn't see it he just moves
the king
oh wow still very winning he just has to
get a plan together and and
just get moving take advantage of the
five-second increment as well if you
move quickly enough
and safely you can build time to then
give yourself more time
to find the actual sequences that you're
looking for
and the one that's in a lot of pressure
here is ollie because she's trying to
find this
maybe trying to find a stalemate trap um
so i would love to listen
to ollie and see what she's saying yeah
see if she uses that
some of that time to her advantage i'll
have to move my king
and then my rook will be eaten and then
it'll be a checkmate
let's try moving here
okay cause he's starting to make some
moves
i can't eat this anymore because the
queen is there
and that rook is awkward because now you
can't place it on c1 or d2
to try to help defend because the night
cover is so squares
what they might to do if i move here and
if you if he moves
this then it'll be a check and then
you'll eat my rook
i'd love to see kizzy move a rook to the
c file
uh oh let's see if she doesn't play with
b2
and oh no oh no oh boy
okay now it's all about finding
checkmate within 30 seconds yes
okay do it because he has the chance
with less than 30 seconds is kizzy gonna
find a sequence
closes this out brings it to one and one
it almost seems like the king is
escaping to the middle of the board
there is he's taking the pawns maybe
trying to get another queen hopefully
there is no stalemate
that would be very unfortunate here
kizzy does have a runner
but he's making space for a meat pattern
which i'd like to do if you're just
going to if you could just take material
make space for yourself make it simpler
because he's starting to limit the
king's available squares
here but this is there might be a
stalemate threat here
the right that would be really
unfortunate
oh gosh oh why did i do that i forgot i
think this is i just had to do something
17 seconds left
just trying to work it out but not much
time
oh my god
almost anything is good here right
almost anything is good here but we got
to remember this time pressure
obviously winning the game and uh
i like the fact that uh that kids he
gave the king another square
the f6 square this is um this is really
nice
under 20 seconds g5 hey
we we do have a few checkmates available
in the position and
luckily for kizzy we white has this d3
pawn that
is one more tempo just in case just in
case
okay here it is right
there's a few checkmates here and there
it is here we go wow
kizzy has done it
kissy has tied the match yes
oh my god
oh my god now i can do this
now i can do this bro now i can do this
wow cause he's got it he he
sing okay confidence
changed all right feeling bad about the
first game now feeling great
can do this
and i think we saw a repeat of the first
match it's just in
his favor because kizzy had a better
opening
but ollie almost seemed like she was
trying to outplay him in the middle game
and it did seem kind of dangerous even
down the queen ollie was finding
extremely good moves for peace activity
yeah and maybe all that extra time could
that have been an indication that ollie
was moving a little bit more quickly
maybe too confidently after that first
victory
yeah maybe maybe
you know chef psychology is a big thing
and oh man i
i just can't wait for the third match
it's kind of torture here waiting for
the third watch i'm ready to go all
right well
let's not let anyone wait too long we're
gonna take a short break and we come
back the third and maybe final game of
this first match so stick around
we'll be back in just a minute
is that it wait really
really wait really
huh oh well
opening principles start course
shall we start a course now we should
let's just
our king can eat too
that was a bad game that was a bad game
i was being too rash
hmm
to be honest i'm not i'm not as
pressured anymore it feels good to
actually lose
it feels really nice
like like it lifts the weight off
now is this game can we do that are we
allowed to do that
it's a book move
is
some good moves but some bad news
i see the blender the blender was the
worst part
it's like what why did you bring the
rook out why did you put the king here
why did you move down why did you bring
this up
yeah there's a lot of
uh that was a really bad move i'm
assuming
ah
it was a messy game from both of you but
it's okay for your level thank you
thank you
it all sat down but it's not over yet
it's not
yes keep going
we should really eat the night back then
with the king
but but it's pretty cool because he only
had 25 seconds and he still kept his
composure and
actually checked me that was pretty cool
that's pretty cool i bet he was going
like
and it's like checkmate that was so cool
that's so cool i really want to shake
his hand
[Music]
i want to shake his hand so bad but we
can't really do that
ah ollie has mad respect for kizzy wants
to shake his hand
well we'll at least have a post-match
interview with the player so definitely
make sure that you stick around for that
between matches and then of course we'll
have our second match of the day esam
versus sagem
but jt one and one with
what could be the last game here
if uh if they don't drop would be the
last game of their own draw
yeah uh at this point it's anybody's
game and
i'm i don't want to play them with
advocating maybe even root for the draw
here because i'm just like how they're
gonna
you know they spend a lot of time in
their game and i'm like how are they
gonna do
under pressure i mean we saw kissy k
overcome that
ali and i actually kind of rooting for
the draw
to see what happens maybe it's a little
diabolical
[Laughter]
definitely diabolical you want to see
some dirty flags and time pressure
but you know what i think probably both
players are feeling enough pressure here
just in this third game
knowing that either player wins it and
moves on to the winners bracket so
uh next game is going to get underway in
just moments here and we're going to see
the
potentially the conclusion of this match
kizzy k playing with the white pieces
and uh here we go
let's see this e4 and then knight c3
i know six of really solid opening are
we gonna get a
four nights and yeah we're gonna four
nights
super solid opening uh bishop b5 yeah
this is this is
literally in the beginner repertoire
here this is
we went to roy lopez oh man
i told you these openings are good you
thought i was joking like these are
actually good openings
yeah they're both playing solidly here
in the first few moves and
uh wow we've this is what an exciting
first match to launch tournament arc
yeah this this is insane because they're
playing
as if they were like 2600s right here
like this is insane this is
actually like extremely good opening
prep for both of them
yeah and remember chat's prediction as
well it was only like 48
to 52 but wait a second bishop takes
f7 uh as i said that um the
commentator's curse is something that we
know in fighting games
[Laughter]
oh no only take the free bishop
yes okay
and now that rook can come to e8 and she
can tuck the king away and it's fine
i wonder i don't know
[Music]
and she misses that she can just take
there
[Music]
or wait maybe there is a tactic with d4
but no too early
wow okay getting two pawns in the bishop
not that bad king k
castle if we can get castles
and d4 this might not be that bad
although we do have to worry about you
know a sneaky b4
and then hitting the e4 pawn
but it's it's looking kind of crazy what
do you think about this ed
because you played d4 yourself right i i
do i do play d4 as white play the
queen's gambit and uh
it definitely results in some sharp
games but uh
so i'm not used to these positions on
the board with uh how these structures
end up with e4 e5
um but
wow i mean i feel like ollie can
actually be comfortable
in a setup like this because she
will probably go on the offensive here
in just a little bit
and uh may fluster kizzy after
what was a very tense first game as
white
i think we might see some like if we can
see maybe d3 or castles
i will be very very happy here
because he could play solidly here and
uh let's listen in on
kizzy for a second see what
is shaping up in his corner
there you have it castle getting the
king safe
and now we know what flows next right
development of pieces and maybe an
attack
if we're allowed to and if we
were able just to play d4 here and then
e5
then i don't know can can casey
find it i think that white has a lot of
potential here
i mean i think i think we're going to
find it i think we're going to really
really find it i
i'm excited because after d6 here
rookie won oh immediately and i i love
this
wow
down a piece this position is going to
get
crazy
we can oh nice
i don't agree with 95. i don't like 95.
kizzy hyper focused here knows what's on
the line
trying to play smart moves and so far
doing a pretty good job
let's uh listen in on the other half of
this equation here
and see how ollie's feeling about things
so far
definitely some strategic
that that's some grand master uh
dialogue there i think i've heard that
over the board a few times
i think this is uh featured in the white
kenzie group uh
group five the queen isn't
my queen is in a tight spot my queen
can't really go anywhere right now
if i go here it'll get in by this if i
go here i'll get eaten by this
or this i don't know or this there's two
attackers
my queen is basically as powerless as
the king
so i might as well stay next to the king
like cover
i think maybe that was morse code gt
what do you think
big boss what's your planning
actually i'm i'm fluent in morse code in
it it wasn't
okay okay hold on a second hold on a
second wait wait wait wait wait wait
you had the perfect setup there to say
it was morse code and what she was
saying was
i i i missed i missed it i was just like
wait
no no listen when it comes to languages
that's one thing
like actually no this is actually what
they're saying oh okay so you were being
you were being ethical yeah i get it yes
yes yes yeah yeah yeah yeah okay not
like some of the
animate like some of the enemy that's
translated and it doesn't have the
correct meanings i
actually gonna give the correct meanings
good host objective
objective commentator we like it okay so
objectively speaking
who's doing better here
listen down a piece or a piece or two
pawns i like
hindi kay's position
and the computer person
[Laughter]
okay i mean what's at stake here uh that
black is maybe
missing about the position oh
um we literally just had to play one
move here and i think that move
is probably a knight here like the d5
the idea is i will then attack
the knight if we take take
everything is pinned uh oh
i mean even then the pieces are just so
good and
i want to give you an idea here um that
a lot of people don't realize is that
black is actually down a piece
temporarily
and they're down the h8 rook it's not
playing
right the king is in a bad place the
king's on f8 and if
we can't activate that rook then we're
you know we're down
essentially we're down a rook right
exactly your player is on the bench
instead of on the field and it's going
to take a bunch of moves
to get that rook active
kizzy of course has to find a way to
take advantage of that right
and right now it seems a little
[Music]
oh i might have spoken being a
commentator's curse again no i have to
stop
commentators girls yeah it's coming
through
it's it's a thing in the fighting
community and like whenever
something bad is going to happen and the
conversators are like wait this is the
easy conversion
drop a combo it's called the american
reset
and there you go kazee takes care of it
he sees the free piece
takes it and now now he's just got to
take this home right and and one of the
things that
we say a lot of people are up material
in a position
is to trade pieces off at that point
right
remove your opponent's ability to have
options with those pieces so
we'll see what happens
this is this is scary for black like
really scary the bishop maybe is now
misplaced
i just hope we don't see knight f5
bishop capture the f5 pawn captures f5
because of the checkmates
right uh and what i'm what i would love
to
see the queen here but um it takes with
the pawn then we have me on the
background
oh wow that's what i don't want to see
that's what i don't want to see
okay
any other than that i think we're doing
i would love to hear what because he's
saying he he's in the driver's seat
again
yes this is his game to lose
and does kizzy notice that the
knight on a5
is also free
after black's next move if it goes
undefended
ollie definitely has a lot of problems
hey there's a lot there's a lot of
problems um
well i must be this way
because he's saying why must it be this
way
why must it be this way bro
the only pressure
because he's actually a freak in my hand
now
damn
ollie activating your queen answering an
attack with an attack so to speak
i would love to see bishop to e3 here
super solid move just
develop the last piece have no trouble
maybe play you know maybe like if they
play g5 then we just play
three and say hey i'm fully developed
you're not you're going down yeah and
trades are good for white
oh yeah yeah trades are awesome we also
have this a very juicy piece of gear
could you perhaps go ahead and take that
knight and allow queen takes d4
because after that then what for black
i i kind of want to hold all my pieces
because this knight is kind of fat right
this knight on a5 compared to this
knight on d4
right this knight on d4 is way stronger
so
i agree with keeping that knight because
now this knight has to move there's only
one place in the knight right
and if we do that then uh you know here
or
here we have ideas of maybe making on a6
you're pushing you know getting a passer
you know oh yeah and uh oh boy
very quick let's see uh
that's all he has to say about her
position ah
stupid stupid ollie stupid
you're stupid
i i didn't know what i was doing too
hmm
you want to have a queen exchange you
can like move your rook here and then we
can have like an exchange
wow and a nice move from kizzy there if
you take with the pawn you lose your
rope legit
legit if you take out the queen you lose
a fish
and that is exactly what happened the
the queen took
so i'll be not necessarily back because
i still
like izzy's position just
trade queens and we're good
great we just have a whole bunch of
extra pawns we have uh
all of our pawns and they and
ollie only has three
and that's where knowing all these
little chess things can come in handy
right
trading when you're up and simplifying
the position for yourself to just win
with a simple enough plan instead of
the most super accurate plan and just
kind of making
life easier for yourself when you're
when you're winning
yeah it's it's a big thing um
because even stronger chess players oh
wait a second oh this this is uh this is
a blog
let's let's look in let's see what's
gonna happen
[Music]
no come on oh come on
then you're going to eat one of my rugs
if i go here you'll eat this drug if i
go there you'll
no no i'm
or ollie this match just has
slipped from her finger she had an
amazing amazing first game
and then struggled to maintain the
momentum
is he just taking his time patiently
working this
and uh queen g5 is almost
almost curtains here um let's see
see what we're going to do i think i
heard uh
mckinsey saying i i understand how this
feels
both players have been very very
sympathetic and
uh and uh uh
showing a lot of respect for each other
i think especially after that first game
and and i think they both have a sense
that they
have been playing quality chess uh in
the opening stage here
and uh
wow
okay now the bishop has to block
if i'm not mistaken rapper's fastbook
and then you can potentially create some
separation afterwards maybe a queen
check on the back rank
to separate the king from defending that
bishop
and then more free stuff right
um that is true that is true we do need
to worry about
some stalemates oh
okay okay
i mean it's not it's never over until
it's over okay oh sure
sure and kissy still has plenty of
material here
you might be flustered by the fact that
that happened but you kind of have to
stop and look at the position and just
say you know what
everything's going to be just fine
right and here a move like knight d4
uh just seems like crushing because
we're threatening a tactic with the uh
rook takes intakes and checkmate in the
back prank
and maybe we have the same plan here
okay
brook takes rook track it is a checkmate
so we have to
be very very careful here
is he telling himself to focus
plenty of time on the clock two and a
half minutes let's see smash bros
not bad i fast so hard
oh my goodness
okay natural move just defend the night
oh my god what what's funny is is there
a stalemate
crap
there is a stanley cup my draw might
come to fruition if crazy ollie would
have
taken the knight
um they take back
we can't move any pieces she would be
out of legal moves
yeah but here unfortunately
we have more legal moves so my ass to
the draw
can't happen here so so ollie is
forced to continue to oh wait or
yeah and now we have
a check with a capture here i feel like
kizzy's gotta have a sense here that
this one's in the bag and he's moving on
all right and let's actually listen and
see because this may be pretty
straightforward from here if he can see
it
yep
stalemate is a lot less likely now that
there aren't any pieces covering across
diagonals that would be
difficult to notice when moving right
uh there there might there are still
some stalemate opportunities here
oh yeah
but um is he is playing this in uh
almost textbook fashions
i'm about to go get a queen bro uh-oh
leave me alone
wants a queen but that might actually
make it complicated
okay
and we'll bring it back to the main
board here and what is
very likely to be the final seconds of
this game
but maybe some congestion here in these
moments i kind of like to get a piece
that doesn't need to be
in the game kind of away from the action
to prevent stalemates
is kissy gonna get greedy here and pick
up another queen
oh man two queens let's see let's see
what's gonna happen here
i mean why not i mean if you don't me
this is tense what any problem
is
is this is this the same you know as a
taunt in a fighting game right now like
he's i think i think that's a taunt i
think that's a danton from street
fighter 4.
playing some
okay this is it right here there has to
be a mate here come on
there's eight billion mates here and oh
my gosh around this person
okay so it's a draw wait what i draw i
don't know if i'm
happy or not i'm not happy about it at
all
and kizzy is i called it
i didn't know the stalemate rule oh no
wow
we have tie breaks
in the first match
of tournament arc what on earth
wow chad right i think this is the flat
armor chat is right this is way too dank
oh my gosh gt can you believe this we're
gonna have a
3-0 tie break match winner takes
all sudden death
can it get any better than this really i
mean you think about it
it it can't this is exactly what i
wanted um thank you
chad for being here um this is my show
we're just gonna have to we're just
gonna have to have you predict every
single outcome ahead of time and and
make them all
uh tie breakers because this is
unbelievable i i i don't want to delay
this any longer we have got to go to
break these we come back we are going to
have a 3-0
tie break match the first pairing of
tournament arc this is unbelievable
stay tuned uh and we'll be right back oh
my gosh
we're just gonna have to have you
predict every single outcome oh my god
and and make them all uh tie breakers
because this is unbelievable what if
it's like another time to play
this any longer we have got to go to
break because we come back we are going
to have a 3-0 type
oh holy of tournament this is
unbelievable
[Music]
myself welcome chess.com viewers this is
the most insane game of chess we've ever
experienced you know the the world chess
championships is going on
right frankly who cares who cares this
is the game of the century right now
this is the game i'm me watching
chess.com this is just not conception
chess this is going to go in the history
books and chess.com this is
as the most thrilling game of chess ever
ever to be experienced
this is truly a game of chess not to be
missed
this is amazing this is insane this game
of chess is literally insane
anyone who isn't here right now is
missing out bro this is
this
no you can't make this up this is
this is such good chance holy
i'm sorry i shouldn't curse on the
chest.com stream i apologize but
this is too exciting i my gosh the the
the
i think everyone at the chess
championships in russia right now is
watching this on their laptops
you know the whole world is watching
this game it's insane
insanity i was here this is good
i i'm very highly anticipating the next
one
we see that ollie has some good ideas
only just panics a little bit right
ollie ollie is great though ollie does
some really good moves
which is really unfortunate uh that
ollie uh blunders a little bit here and
there but overall
good stuff was it really oh my god
oh this is crazy
this is crazy i was here i know
i was here i this was here
to be in the history books you know you
have uh you have uh
uh gary uh kasparov versus
deep blue and uh ollie versus kizzy
these are the two most famous games of
chess in human history
i'm telling you guys
watch my mic saying still all right this
is truly insane
truly truly beautiful games of chess oh
my god i'm very excited for the next one
i can't wait
chess.com why are you keeping us give us
the next game already we're waiting
we need to see the outcome of this
we are going to give it to you connor
you asked for it and
and we're here we're here we were here
jt
when holly had kissy
into tie breaks after a stalemate with a
bishop
oh my god
how did we get here it's your fault
right this is your fault
it's my fault it's my fault i apologize
but um
you know this is basically an anime
continuing right like this is the second
season that we wanted
and well this is more like a an art
sorry about that
it's called the tournament arc
yes get it right get it right jt we are
here we are here tournament r2
and the tie break is going to start any
second it is three minutes
with no increment that means you do not
gain time for moving quickly
you just have to win and here we go the
game is underway oh my gosh
here we go
i need to hear what ollie is thinking i
just need to know
right how she feels after two losses you
know what let's just do one more
a loss and a draw but it felt like a
loss that's our safest bet right now
okay she's playing safe right quick
opening
developing moves yep not a lot of time
so moving quickly is good
i think it's starch this is uh let's
just play it safe right now
you're pinning my king awesome
okay the king is not going to go here
ollie likes that move b4
continuing to make you move that
yeah let's just do a normal italian
opening i think that's the best way
we're practically doing the same thing
uh that's some free stuff
but wait a minute
are there tactics gt
what is happening here where are the
opportunities
hey what opportunities huh
oh there um there might be an
opportunity uh
very very soon i think uh oh okay oh no
is it a commentator's curse
if it becomes equal yeah
yes yes you literally like you're not
supposed to even compensate so basically
finding a community
you're not supposed to say what's about
to happen because it's not going to
happen
absolutely oh he's just going to finish
his combo
matter of fact he's drawn a combo uh and
he lost the game
this just usually happened
oh my
now the king doesn't have a castle to go
back to awesome
is she just in shock she didn't even
comment on losing her queen
we have a double pawn too this isn't
looking good
but let's not forget she could still
flag him he's like down almost a full
minute
almost a full minute no increment
to be honest this isn't really
protecting the king that much she's just
gotta calm down
this piano is protecting maybe look at
the clock
what can we expect now i don't know
can we see what he's thinking about
because he's literally
down almost a minute now
he just said stressful dude
spending a lot of time thinking about
moves
oh my gosh
ollie would double his time now more
than more than a minute
you have to play fast here because
you're winning but
got to move okay he gives up a bishop
here
but if you activate your other pieces
and move quickly coming up on less than
30 seconds here for kizzy k
ollie with a little over a minute
oh my gosh gt this is gonna come down to
the wire man
oh man yeah i don't i don't know i don't
i don't know whose game this is this is
this is crazy
oh man this is okay you're getting
crazier by the second oh my gosh
what's happening here wild
i am literally not even gonna talk about
the chess right here i'm just gonna say
i hope they have a good game
i'm not getting blamed i'm not
oh my gosh 15 seconds one more
you got to move you got to make moves
eleven i think
10 less oh my gosh kizzy is
you got a flag here he probably thinks
that he has he probably thinks that he
has increment he doesn't
oh no three seconds go go move move move
oh no this is it he only gets
like three and that's it
it's over wait is this is it is this is
this
does this count as a win is this a win
is this oh is this okay what does this
mean
i don't know oh no
what does this mean oh what does that
mean
[Music]
what does it mean it's time bro
oh man kizzy knows that it's over but
ollie baby is just in shock that she's
done it
she's come away with a win in the first
match
wow wow
ali is going to move on to the winner's
bracket and
kizzy moves down to the redemption arc
that's it
but you know it's never over until it is
completely over so
that kind of because because he played
an amazing chest unbelievable chess
um so
if casey can keep that up we might see
him in grand finals
i'm hoping i'm rooting for everyone to
bring their best chess if even if they
lose
just bring bring their best chess in
that redemption
yeah and we'll find out from the players
right now how they feel about
the paths that they will take moving on
in tournament r2 in just a few moments
we're gonna have
our first post-match interview with
crazy ollie and kizzyk so stick around
do not miss this we'll talk to the
players in just a few minutes
[Music]
in grand finals i'm hoping i'm rooting
for everyone to bring their best chess
if they even if they
oh my god oh my god ollie right now how
they feel about
the paths just a few moments we're gonna
have
our first post match interview with
crazy ollie and kizzyk so stick around
do not miss this we'll talk to the
players in just a few minutes
i cannot believe ali won that
holy in grand finals i'm hoping i'm
rooting for everyone to bring their best
chassis they're watching me oh my god oh
we're watching me
oh my god i went to the i went to the
drake
toilet
i don't know if chess.com is back yet
but hi
um yeah th this is what's live for me
i can't believe this this is insane
i should put it on the full screen right
oh my gosh that was insane it was
actually insane
what a game what a first game
oh man like i'm so proud of ollie
um you also got a feel for kissy there i
mean you know you had the dot
and then you you know you get the draw
and then you lose it's like oh my god
that would feel so bad
i would i would i would feel bad
that's uh that's rough that is rough
but i mean great game seems though
great games my gosh
oh my god all right uh ollie's live
right now right
okay
i mean i'm sending a super chat right
now
looking for my car details
i want an apex
i want apex
[Music]
that was so good oh my god
that's so funny i i really say my super
chat i did there's my super chats there
i wanna apex uh oh no it's happening
it's happening
oh dear oh dear um i think they gotta do
it
[Music]
is
loading up apex dot txt exe sorry
a couple of ollie world that's so good
oh they're gonna be on the chest.com
thing all right they're gonna be on
stress.com
just.com viewers was that not the best
game of chess you've ever witnessed in
your lifetime
that was truly a spectacle that was
amazing that was
truly amazing i got messaged me
actually insane oh
that was that was crazy oh my lord
i can't believe that that was uh
it was good stuff with the interview
oh okay i think they're gonna start
their interview soon i'm excited for
this interview i'm excited for the
post-match discussion of that
epic epic clash of titans
that was insane that was so good
that was so good
[Music]
i've got a tweet i can't believe i just
got to
witness most exciting
[Music]
did i spawn witness wrong i think i just
spelled no i didn't i thought i put one
s there for a second
sorry i shouldn't be discussing my
spelling
all right and we are back with the
players uh
what an unbelievable match and uh
kizzy i'd actually like to start with
you what was that like
coming back in game two and then
having that draw take you into uh
into a tiebreaker uh to to finish the
match out
so honestly i was like the first
game definitely was like oh man i
like i just got played right and then so
the second game i was just like all
right
uh you know they do a different type of
like unique
opening and i i capitalized on the queen
really early so i felt like
i had like a lot of like you know board
control
after that and then after that you know
you know i was able to secure that and
then the third game uh i realized i was
looking at the timer and i was like oh i
gotta do something right
but as i was like thinking of doing
something i was thinking of like
three other things and it looked like
everything
passed over that like yeah i have to
like do something otherwise it's gonna
become a draw
but also i was so like in the mind of
just trying to like
basically get a guaranteed win when i
should have just
won with the things i had what i mean by
guaranteeing me i was like
oh let me get all of these things and
just like you know
overrun right but i forgot that that's
not how that works
so after i lost i was like dang
you know like all right so now all right
we can probably play another game right
and then
it said three minutes and i was like oh
it's over like
i'm going to lose right now i got three
minutes i'm already bad with tom so
now you're gonna give me left time oh
good games
i was like oh good game she won yeah and
that last game actually was really
impressive chess from both of you jt i
know you've got questions for ollie so
i'm gonna let
um you played amazing chats um
especially that last game you were
playing so fast
what was going through your head in that
last game because you know
going from winning to losing the second
game
and then drawing the third game when you
thought i think you were like oh no
no i'm losing i'm losing and then
winning the last one how did you feel
i sincerely did not know what i was
doing
to be very blunt to be very sincere
i i i was because kizzy i did so many
blenders and kissy kept on eating all my
pieces i
i i just so the thing that came to my
mind is like okay i just gotta move
fast i can move like sonic gotta go
you know that's all actually
well i got i got okay so
but that was really cool though you keep
you kept on eating my pieces he kept on
trapping me i did so many blenders
man it was so cool it was a good game
yeah it was
it was a good game yeah and and we
actually were able to listen into both
of your streams during the match and
you were both saying really
complementary things of each other the
entire way
uh which we we found made a lot of sense
obviously we're very happy
that uh you both have a lot of respect
for each other and i i wanted to ask you
kizzy
do you feel like maybe part of that had
to do with sort of the uh
i i we we weren't sure what to expect
here but what we did get from both of
you was very strong
chess very principled chess and um how'd
you feel about that did you feel like uh
like ollie was putting up a good
challenge for you but also you know
oh yes she was all she was smoking me in
my whole
my whole time i was literally playing i
was stressed out
even when i was when i was stressed
because i'm like what is she gonna do to
come back
right so i'm sitting here stressed out
and then i'm thinking on top of the back
of my head
that if i lose i'm gonna be an apex and
minecraft player so i
already got double the stretch right so
i am like losing
so i can't i'm like oh man panda's gonna
get madden
right so then i'm like oh okay you know
i i overcame i overran i got the second
game and then third game i was like yo
i got it and then i failed fell down
fell down she got away
and she went to get we went to game four
and she
she she was on it and i i i was still i
was still like revving the engine you
know
and i just got overran with the speed
and i just couldn't keep up and i got
out played
and jt i wanted to ask you obviously
ollie did what she needed to do to
secure the match and she's going to move
on to the winner's side of the bracket
her next opponent will either be
techtone or russege
you're very familiar with both of them
what do you think ollie needs to do
in order to prepare for that next
matchup
i think you need to believe in yourself
a little bit more you know you're a good
player
we saw a lot of principal chess and i
really complimented you during the
stream because
you were able to find really good plans
and ideas
focus on getting a little bit more
familiar with the opening
and being confident in your ideas
because you had
great ideas in in the middle game so
it it really surprised me you know so
congratulations on the win
and i hope that i will see more good
chess from you
i'll try my best and um
i i really like you you played a really
good openings you played solidly
you try to get you know the center of
the opening and really impressed by you
so
um even though you did when like you're
still a winner because that was
tough that was great well i i want to
thank
you know uh you and anna for actually
just
you know just sitting there just
physically taking the time and kind of
like helping and like i said like i'm
really one of those
learners that need to experience type of
things so
the more i get experience the more
understanding what decisions i have to
do right
so uh as i was playing i felt like i was
gradually getting an
understanding even when there was stuff
that was kind of like new
but i still kind of remember the
principles of what i needed to do and
what
had so much gamepl and it actually makes
me want to play the game more so
uh i actually ordered me a chess ball uh
lap uh
earlier today you're so you're helped
yeah definitely
something so definitely you definitely
got me you know i also
i also downloaded uh i got origin so i
got apex downloaded too
and i don't know how much minecraft cost
but like you know we got checking that
out
and yeah so i'm learning three games now
apex we're going to apex right
i mean i just got smoked i got i got i
got a i gotta breathe
you know i gotta i gotta i gotta go out
and i gotta go
you know think about this i gotta play
the theme the minecraft theme you know i
gotta let it
let it marinate you know right now it's
still marinating but
we definitely gonna play i promise well
you'll both get a chance to create it
yeah you'll you'll definitely both get a
chance to breathe uh
because your next match won't be until
thursday
next weekend and um we wish you both the
best of luck uh maybe you'll get some
extra coaching sessions in with uh
with anna kremling or others and we will
bid you a due for now and uh we'll see
you again on thursday
great chess guys yup thank you
thank you there you have it
both uh kizzy k and ollie will be
moving on and we will see them again on
thursday
and uh we will know tomorrow after the
match between techtone and russege
who they will each be facing in their
next matchups
jt wow what a result right
it was a match it was quite a match it
was up downs and
i didn't expect it to be so up and down
but this is what i wanted and
i got it so i'm very happy to see this
it was uh amazing it was
the best match we could have started
with honestly
great way to start tournament arc and up
next we
cannot wait any longer they have uh the
players have been very patient here as
we've gone into tie breaks and had our
interview but it's time
we're going to flip the coin and we're
going to see between sagem and esam our
next pairing who is going to start out
with the white pieces
and all right esam
is going to play white in the first
match we are going
to go to break and uh when we come back
game one of our second match of the day
esam
versus sagem fgc on fgc here we go
see you in just a moment
he's going to start out with the white
pieces and
all right esam what are their ratings i
actually don't know i know that
saddam is like 1 000 i think to break
and i don't know what you sam's rating
is that
game one of our second match of the day
esam
versus sagem fgc on fgc here we go when
is your game
i'm not playing today so it's only
they're only doing two series a day
oh it's me okay i gotta all right
all right
welcome to chess.com viewers uh i'm i'm
here to scout out my competition as i'm
playing tomorrow the uh either the
winner or the loser of this game i don't
know
i just need to have a look just so i
know what's going on i'm sure garnet is
watching too
gone if you're watching this um better
loose
to me
tomorrow that's uh that's that's all
and then i have this is that made
oh they can go that way
i mean it's little tape and i get out of
there
and then i can it's going to yell at me
i think i go here
and i take i am back over 1900 puzzles
um
okay
like ignore the queen i mean
oh because i pushed because then yeah
okay that makes sense
anyway
those are great you guys sometimes i
have no idea
i mean yeah mods can technically talk
all right i'm gonna turn my music back
on
uh what music do i wanna listen
ontario theme so good i love this music
[Music]
oops
because i am nervous
saw that i was on stream hello everyone
from
chess.com how are you doing that match
was kind
of insane and kizzy through which is
unfortunate because i'm on the same team
as him
[Music]
i don't know what else to
say
i'm so nervous uh chess tournaments look
so nerve-wracking i was saying this on
my stream and i don't know if i'm still
live on trust.com but
there's a difference between playing
casual chess and competitive chess it is
so stressful that every single move
matters so much
also if you haven't already check out
fighting games fighting games are sick
i know i think a lot of you are anime
tuber fans because i think the anime
tubers are bigger than all the fighting
game creators but
fighting games are sick check out guild
to gear check out smash ultimate or
melee or
any fighting game the nickelodeon
fighting game that's coming out pretty
cool
pretty cool check it out when it comes
out just saying
[Music]
hello now it is mirrored but i muted so
it's okay
cindy fonterra let's go ragnarok baby
[Music]
so i think for those of you that aren't
aware we have an 1100 rated and i think
sagram is like 780 so
hopefully that works in my favor i know
i played white first because i was
watching the mainstream when it
showed up so i'm stressed
i'm really stressed i should not
have cursed
but it's okay
that was hilarious welcome back
everybody and it's time
let's just get the first game going
while you and i chat a little about
uh reminding people of the format here
this is a best of three match between
esam and sajam and uh so the first
player to get to two points will win
the match they're going to be playing 15
minutes on or
10 minutes on each of their clocks uh
with a five second increment per move
and uh jt we got a
we got a different set here of players
they both
have practiced a lot and gotten lessons
from really strong
chess players uh e sam uh from
his uh compatriot over at panda global
and a kremling
uh master chess player and then sagem
from
from myself and uh from the one and only
international master danny wrench
uh this is gonna be some strong chess
what do you think are you excited for
this one
i'm so excited um this is gonna be crazy
this the
the first one the first round sick
this round is going to be even better i
think
it's just going to complete the whole
day uh i'm waiting
and i can't wait enough i'm going to the
games i
they're they're playing fast they know
what they're doing he sam with
eleven hundred and eleven elo that would
sage him
going uh that's a great name uh 753
but i'll say it man like if you look at
sagem's game history you're gonna find
that that 753
may only be due to the fact that he just
hasn't played enough games
for that rating to really reflect what i
think is his true strength
these guys are going to be way more
evenly matched than it looks on paper
yeah we see some open stuff that knights
out the bishop out
and very quickly within the first 30
seconds of the game
and now what right now what should we
block play
you got to get your pieces out as well
right you got to get your bishop you got
a castle
you got to get your other bishop out
right super simple and
you're absolutely right you're playing
all the right moves yep and let's see uh
we haven't had a listen to sagem yet
so we'll start there and take a listen
see how he feels about playing black in
this first game yeah i don't know if i
should castle the same way but i'm gonna
uh that's also probably fine i think i
should just
develop something to protect that so
either this pawn
or this one i
think i'll i'll just do this right
that might not be the best move but
that's just my plan of attack i don't
know if it's the right move
just seeing the sophisticated in the
chat really cracks me up you know that
you guys just crack like you guys are
funny children i'll never say that again
i can just also put the bishop on okay
important if i take here
it's fine to trade here right
yeah this seems fine
i think i
i kind of feel like i should just push a
knight now actually
because my knight doesn't really need to
defend
it doesn't attack this piece anymore
really
uh i could also just bring this
out on the diagonal that also seems fine
i kind of want to move this pawn at some
point too
see jam's doing okay so far he's uh he's
talking himself through the opening
stage of this game here and he was
worried about those two pawns and maybe
they are awkward but
is it necessarily a bad thing right now
for black
not at the moment i am those pawns could
be good with a
center d5 break maybe saying i can play
c65
and maybe put some pressure with c4 at
some point um and then
you're gonna undouble pretty easily if
the
knight if white's knight wants to play
like knight d5 then you know at least
you cover c5 and you cover
sorry um yeah d6 and c5 covering d5
uh and d4 yeah maybe really important
squares
move that double pawn towards the center
one of the main breaks here is just to
play d4 so if we can get that and
especially with the bishop here
it looks like a pretty good plan so
these double pawns aren't necessarily
bad
right now but in the end game they could
be
we definitely got some sagem fans in the
chat i see those animated emotes
hello everybody welcome at the fgc
in the house right here first match
between say jam and esam esam
is a uh i would just say a legendary
pikachu player
in uh in the smash game i think best
pikachu
uh in the last uh 10 11 years but say
jam's also been on the scene for about
the same time as a commentator
and uh just generally awesome ambassador
of the fighting game community and um
also kind of holding his own here so far
in the game against
e sam who's actually been a premium
member of chess.com for over a year
and very active i have to say
oh i don't know that okay
um i'm probably the best fox
um in my neighborhood so i have that
going for me i mean that's a big
neighborhood that's that's that's like
that's like uh brooklyn man
yeah i i can do some combos i can do
some fox combos
you say neighborhood like it's a small
thing but
maybe i don't know maybe you talk esam
into uh
into a smash stream oh oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah when he's done with this uh i'll
show him something
oh we're gonna have to talk about that
during the interview
all right i like this i've idea
i like knight g5 and
the idea might be just to play f4
because this is one of the only breaks
uh white has white has and when i talk
about breaks i'm talking about pawn
breaks and what those are are moves that
can change the position
and open up files right so we develop
all of our pieces now we need to find
a way to attack and the easiest way is
upon break
and i actually would have appreciated
this night i actually went to h3
to support this f4 break because if they
want to stop this f4 break then if they
play g5 which is an extremely weakened
move
and then we can maybe play yeah f3
knight of two
king f you know and then bring this rook
over somewhere
and attack and play h4 and really mess
up king
the black king's position yeah and maybe
say jam is measuring that right now and
saying you know what
like maybe i need to be patient here
right and see
see what esam does um and let's uh let's
take a listen again to say jam and see
uh how this is going for him so far yeah
that is a problem i stopped defending
this pawn which
i should i should develop this yeah i'm
just gonna develop my queen man i'm so
down on time i just probably should do
something
okay plan of attack develop the queen
probably get the rook out from there
this bishop is just stuck so i kind of
want to move my knight here just
even if it's not great i should probably
just free up this bishop to do something
because it's kind of stuck all my pieces
are kind of in a bad spot i feel like
uh that's fine right if knight takes
then bishop
takes and then i'm not in that bad of a
position am i
i guess he takes with the pawn and then
he can push the pawn
i could just retreat the queen or i
could move it forward
and i love the conversation he's having
him with himself like
this is exactly how chess players should
think
um well quite surprised even at that
rating like you have very
clear logical you know plans and ideas
and
oh that's a nasty fork knight takes c7
hits the rook and the queen and
discovers an attack against the queen
with the bishop on c4 and this is this
is that's nasty
yeah this is pretty bad um
but he said he has to see him up and
there you go yeah
well essential is up four minutes on the
clock
almost half the time right he has 50
more
this is insane yeah
and and that may be a result of a number
of things easy development with
with uh a good opening understanding and
just solid simple moves
um coupled with maybe say jam suffering
for a little bit of decision paralysis
about what to do next maybe talking
about those plans is obviously a good
thing
but only for so long right and then you
got to make moves
let's see how esam feels about his
position so far take a look in the
stream and we'll listen
[Music]
it's jamming i think he's taking musical
cues from crazy ollie
might be the good luck charm
i was jamming too i was like oh man this
is this is i gotta add this to my
playlist
he's doing all right and uh yep making
some
patient moves here uh uh-oh is cj's
queen
starting to run out of squares here
luckily we always have that h7 square
that we can kind of retreat back to
like just a boom and then
you know something like this or yeah
just immediately
yeah but you kind of put an a nice like
a
important piece to your to your attack
plans like on the bench
now this is a very very important moment
for white and something that a lot of
players don't realize
is that this h pawn is now a passer and
this is
huge because okay the pawn
here is not very important but if this
pawn gets a sixth rank
you have to start paying attention if it
comes to the seventh rank
it ties down a piece
well let's see if esam
can break through the jams a little bit
if this bishop stays here i do have to
look out for it later because i feel
like i can
fall into like a checkmate or something
i really would like that to not
happen
[Music]
and like this pawn is now pinned so if
seigen moves here i have to take because
i just
[Music]
hmm
okay yep he sees that exchange doesn't
quite end in his favor
doing a decent job of just checking on
the end of an exchange making sure
that it's uh that it's either beneficial
or dangerous
and honestly like this you can't okay
there is one plan that's stagia the sage
needs to see here uh i think
seeing this idea of knight
the h5 and then knight to f4
could potentially be troublesome of
course you always have 98 but they have
to find it right
right um but then we can also take with
check because the queen is fitting the
pawn
so you have to be very careful
right we and the king might get a bit
looser
and in situations like this then a move
like knight d4 might be extremely strong
and this pin i mean if you were going to
play this pin
then you should have played instead of
queen g6 when you played you should have
played queen to
h5 before right
because now you wasted a move you gave
your opponent an extra move
but something has changed in
sejam's you know calculation where it's
like okay this
has to be the best square for mcqueen
now
maybe true but also someone's gotta
change with his time management or he's
gonna let this first game go
just simply on the clock let's uh see if
he's aware of that
this isn't fair you know i was just
thinking about this fighting game
matches are 99 seconds all smash matches
are like 37 minutes right
because they're like we don't we can't
have timeouts all of our matches have to
be 37 minutes long
with like no items on like this stage
this guy is cheating he's actually just
he's built different he's prepared for
this
when i put it like that no wonder he's
good at chest
what if all the pieces were queens
originally and some smash player was
just like
we can't have that now we got to make an
arbitrary list of rules that these
pieces are allowed
to do because your queen beat up my
queen and i don't like it
that's cold
the problem is like you know i move my
queen there thinking
[Music]
interesting i think the plan is to move
the queen
that seems fine i think he wants to
attack with the
bishop on this square right but i have a
space to retreat to with the king
so is it that bad he did deny this move
which is the move i was thinking about
making
right it kind of limits my knight but i
don't know if that's the end of the
world
only time will tell and maybe a lot less
time to say jam thinks he's only got
is under two minutes now i
i don't know what to say i mean he just
has to move a little bit faster
yes i mean he has to realize like hey
i'm sticking down my opponent is playing
good moves and i have to find
moves faster but whether there'd be good
moves or bad moves i mean we still have
to be in the game at the end of the day
see jim making his move and i think you
know in a position like this
esam could look at his six minutes and
30 seconds and say you know what
maybe i can just play patient chess here
and let say jam defeat himself in this
first game
so to go off of that and
when you know your opponent is in time
trouble you don't want to make it easy
for them
right so they played 95 for a reason to
try to trade off
um this night for a bishop
right and if we just play bishop a2 here
now they have to find another plan now
okay now what are you going to do
right and if we can play to that where
they have only a minute and 30 seconds
left
go ahead it's your move and bishop is
not a bad move either
right that's the kind of work that i
would play in blitz
very smart very smart yeah patient chess
here
and okay he's maneuvering his knight
saying queen trades fine we'll we'll
trade those things off that'll be one
less piece i have to think about on
the side of my where my king is castled
and
and still he's saying you know what this
is on you i mean look he's even saying
right now maybe
in gestures like you're moved what are
you gonna do say jam
[Music]
let me stop messing around
i just have to remember i literally just
have to remember this whole
time he declined
because i don't care like if you take
here that's fine this is all fine
[Music]
push there's two defenders
and three or two attackers three
defenders so this is fine
we got to the same position with the
same amount of time and
i hopefully i mean i would love it if
white found this
really really nice move uh queen to a4
you know with the pin the knight can't
be defended so
it just looks winning and
if you take we have a check first
but um it wasn't found but you know at
the same time
you're up so much time that any of you
make
should be winning and time is a piece
too right
you have to calculate the amount of time
that you have
you know and the other thing that i just
noticed about esam
is these last few moves have come very
quickly he's already thought about the
exchanges before they occur
so that he knows he can just take take
take and
the pressure continues to be on sagem's
clock and not his own
i wonder what cjm is thinking here with
these moves this is uh
this is interesting does he have a plan
or is he just
throwing material out there and and
hoping that something
something an opportunity arises
he has so much time ah
yes so much time that's fine i think i
have to
[Music]
i have to do this which loses me the
bishop
it loses you something a little bit more
valuable
but i don't have a lot of other options
right like i kind of have to do that
okay and we'll see where oh
i think i should rather than the rook
maybe is there a story there
i agree with that yeah i agree with that
um the bishop was the only thing that
was attacking the king
and you just want to be safe right why
the bishop
could take on f3 and then the queen can
take on f3 it gets kind of scary
why even allow that
and here if uh is not
careful we have queen to e4 check
hitting the king and hitting the knight
oh wow
we have to be very careful here
yeah esam is definitely on the move
feeling fairly
safe i'm not sure that
uh the knight and queen can really
coordinate here
especially like you said actually that
bis that bishop trading for the night
could have been
uh the turning tide that sagem needed
and right here we have three connected
passers we have the pawn on a3
we have the pawn on v4 and then we have
the pawn on c4
so here even if we lose a piece
we're already up because these three
pawns are going to roll
their future yeah if we have two
connected passers on the sixth rank
they are worth a piece and it's gonna be
a piece of our choice
and if sagem wants a stalemate he can
get a bishop right
so um never forget see what he said was
saying because i or singing yeah this is
literally
where we're singing yeah
[Music]
this feels like the outro music too in
anime
[Music]
no time and sagam is
out of time that is it
cjm goes down that was the problem the
time is the problem
damn well that was pretty good okay
damn i feel like i made like wonder if
they're gonna do anything i didn't
really know what this is
i mean we definitely see that look at uh
e sam over there
already scrolling through the game and
hey say jam as well they're
they're diving right in i don't know
that they're even gonna take advantage
of this five minute break to go get a
drink or
or go to the bathroom they they want to
know what happened here
they are i mean this is isn't this kind
of true
and expected of fighting game players to
really maximize these
uh these moments between matches to
study their play and their opponents
play
um yeah but in the final game community
there's there's no breaks you go right
in
you know you get one break like if you
want to go back to character select
and that's the only break you have and
you can only really change
up openings or change up characters if
you lose
so when you're expected to play the same
character with the same you know special
and stuff like that so it's a different
dynamic and it's
i don't know it's proving to be really
uh effective
um i think both actually logical players
and i'm i'm loving these games
yeah the same it's not a watch either
way it
yeah absolutely the same and and i feel
like uh
maybe who knows maybe the benefit of
being able to analyze
where you maybe can't in the fgc uh
is something that uh that might really
help say jam here so let's take a break
and we come back game two of esam versus
sagem tournament r2
coming at you in just a moment
i think i did fine until that right
there to be honest with you
i i play like i didn't really know
exactly what i was supposed to do here
and i've never faced this
so i think i did okay up until this
point
yeah this is a problem
yeah he is the thing is he is a better
he is a better chess player than i am
right he has he's played more and he's
better and he has more
experience so especially in positions
like this i don't really know what to do
very much in a lot of positions so i
i have to sit and think right that
that's the issue like for him because
he's played much more
he has more like it just comes and he's
like okay i know what i want to do here
so i know time is going to be a factor
so i should probably just make my moves
faster even if they're going to be wrong
is the way i should do it because i you
know i need it yeah i got my queen stuck
too
he just um he just uh what's it called
i also think i had one good moment where
i had like this
wait let me look is there something
better i could have done over
here no right i'm just losing super bad
here
yeah i don't have any any moves yeah
that's the problem right it's like
i should probably play faster because
you know i'm gonna run out of time and
because he
is probably more familiar with what to
do anyway okay all right
fair enough fair enough
yeah to be honest with you most of the
trades that i was thinking about doing
uh or most of trades i i didn't take
were not because
i thought to myself i don't want to take
this trade it's because i didn't think
about it i was too busy
thinking about developing pieces and not
thinking about taking pieces on the
board does that make sense
didn't sing enough soul theme yeah
yeah i just need more time okay this
slide i feel a little bit better about
playing white here though
i have like a bit more of a cohesive
plan so we'll see
we'll see find your one way is is it own
way or
one way because a lot people in chat
kept saying one way and i'm not sure
i don't think isn't it own way
is it one way that does not make sense
how is it one way
what it's find your one way
it's guilty gear lyrics that makes per
when you put it like that that makes
perfect sense
you you're one and only way
yeah but it's your only way it shouldn't
be find your one
way find your one way that does not make
sense to me
find your one way as and find your own
one way no that doesn't make sense to me
it doesn't make any sense okay i've got
a plan on this side though i don't wanna
i
i'm just like uh it's kind of in my
brain already so at least in white he
always
he usually plays the same opening right
so it's a little easier on this side but
that's not to say that my prep time will
help me too much but i do have a plan
stp sdp is the way
play the disaster of passion dude
imagine these poor chess commentators
imagine these poor chest commendators
indeed
we are back and uh i will say
however that i'm feeling what seijin was
just saying
um during his break on stream that uh
he's gonna collect himself a little bit
he's not feeling any kind of
any kind of tilt or anything he's he's
made some decisions about what his
approach is gonna be here in the second
game and
and he doesn't feel like he's out for
the couches yet
yeah i i think that um if he plays a
little bit faster
and i mean it was really clean
i'm not gonna deny that the fact that
issan was super clean
in his opening prep and in his movements
um but he
he just doesn't have enough time to
think he needs to move a little bit
faster in the opening
yeah well we'll see that here whether or
not this comes true because
game two is going to start right now and
uh sagem and esam stay jam now with the
white pieces as they alternate colors
and
okay e4 d6 i feel like
actually in danny's lesson with say jam
they talked about this
and it's going to be interesting to see
if stage
uh said stageham i want to call him
stageham because it's just so good
uh if he follows the lines that they
discussed
okay oh yeah please
yeah good lines these are good lines
so far sagem is making good on his
promise to move more quickly
although now yeah this is probably in my
mind would be my first thing all right
like he's in my house like what do i do
this is one of the lines that i
recommend um for
for white against the pier to set up or
against the modern defense
so glad to see it being implemented here
okay now you wonder take back with the
queen of the pond takes back with the
queen
i like taking back with the pawn
actually in some lines yeah
um and then playing bishop e3 queen d2
and then
potentially uh using your rooks to get
onto the h1 and g1
move your king to f1 and attack
and um let's go ahead and
put that on the boards like just taking
with the pawn up because now the g file
is it's open
gonna rook over here and get a rook on
the g power and maybe put the king
on g2 put both rooks over here
and then bring the king back and now you
have a huge attack
wow well
we'll see now i guess the question on
sagem's mind
is what do i do about my d4 pawn now
i think that satan should just take and
take um we have some really nice
development options here
here and then we have rook d1 and this
is going to be
vertical here i think this is going to
put
a lot of pressure on black's position
yep and the time starts to whittle down
again here
cgm tries to figure out the best way to
deal with
this attack in the center and uh
people will also kind of see uh
what e sam thinks is his plan
to move forward from here
that's very much the skill i'm trying to
learn to not
go stupid go crazy you know
[Music]
seems comfortable
i started him to like put his rook here
or something and i just moved my queen
[Music]
so about to be on dark square son i'm
not getting like randomly
okay it sounds to me like esam it just
kind of is already
contingency upon contingency you're
gonna do this i'll do that
i'm ready to move when you are
i i think that the night move here was a
little bit premature and i i wish like
maybe we would have seen like bishop g5
because then that knight d5 becomes so
powerful
but this is not a bad way to play it
either
because our bishop has a little trouble
developing but i think the natural
square is maybe e2 and then we try to
control the d-file right
this is one of the plans here
um and then
f5 needs to happen maybe so maybe just
click king over
f5 but we need to get our pieces active
we need uh this rook to
get some life we need uh maybe something
like this here
or actually maybe not even that we can
just keep this rook here maybe bring
this room to default or e-file
yep
it was the beginning of this plan to get
the rooks into the game here
um after maybe knight b6 i attack your
bishop
you have to move now i get my rook in
place i'm happy to trade
starting to look pretty good
and for those of you who like our anime
fans
you might think that you know esam is
just like he's an ultra instinct right
now because
just playing really really fast chess
but if you
if you notice he's actually thinking on
his opponent's time
and it's a concept that even some
torment players don't really understand
it is your job to sit at the board and
understand the moves you shouldn't get
up from your board unless you absolutely
have to
make sure you understand your position
completely
and work through everything and so he's
the time that
sagem is thinking about it
he sam is also thinking about it and so
when
satan moves now he says like okay i just
spent two minutes thinking i don't have
to think anymore because i already saw
this plan
yeah and um he's not having as
much uh trouble as he did in that first
game
on the clock sagam is still
hanging on here a deficit but not nearly
as deep as before
all right so uh we have here knight c5
nice c5
not a bad move i i actually quite like
the smooth
and i'm gonna get the uh the bishop pair
back say hey you can't have this bishop
repair anymore
and the reason the reason the bishop
player is pretty good is that in the end
game
they're long range pieces and if there's
play on both sides
the bishop is a better piece in the end
game although knights can be extremely
tricky
so let's see what happens here let's see
what uh
stage m wants to do actually we'd listen
in to see what
this line of thought is and you read my
mind
right there's nothing i guess the the
queen can take
but this is still i think good for me
right i should just take with the
yeah i think i should just take because
even if the queen takes after
i don't think that's that bad for me
yeah i'm just gonna do it i don't know
if it's the right idea but i'm gonna
take it
because now i'm not immediately under
attack there anyway
uh okay
i should probably get my pieces moving i
want to get this rook
out in a better position but i don't
really know exactly what to do with it
it's also under attack now it's not that
bad though right
yeah i need to start getting some pieces
forward i think
i'll just do this i don't think it's the
best move but i think it's okay
i just don't have that much time
everybody calm down something is better
than nothing here right
because he can't take otherwise i'll
just take my bishop and it's fine
so he's probably he has to push
something else on the board either has
to move his bishop or he has to try to
like
get his rooks in the middle of the board
which is also still fine
especially because if his rook on the
king side moves i just attack with the
queen right
and then he's just like immediately in
trouble all right so cgm
continue to work this thing out
definitely conscious of his clock
which is a good sign and and the the uh
look the
the difference is actually starting to
narrow a little bit
if i were to put a rating on this game i
would honestly say that
these players are playing double
their ratings right now
wow this is this is a game that you
would probably see around the 21
2000 range like they have played really
good just so far
so uh this is this is insane like
they're thinking strategically their
structure is really good
um they really haven't made any mistakes
so far like the first one was a little
bit
suspicious but this one is so strong
yeah and what do you think about that
i liked it i liked it because the one
that you do want to play as black is
f5 that's that was the point
uh and you can't i don't think you can
take on f7 because of queen e7
putting more pressure on the default
yeah getting a rook
on the seventh ranked which is uh
another concept right another
strong concept yeah wow and uh supported
by the bishop as well on b3 i mean look
at say jam all sudden he's coordinating
on a specific square i mean this is not
an accident
you don't just make moves like this
especially rook d7 it's got intent
and that's what he needs right now i
wonder
i wonder if esam is actually feeling
some pressure here because
because there's a real attack going on
here
[Music]
[Applause]
oh like this gives black a slight edge
here
[Music]
with that f5 i really enjoy f5 i wonder
when
[Music]
what's aj was gonna do here
this is some real kenny g vibes going on
here right now
yeah now we saw him
looking at maybe f4
which would kind of close things up in
in some senses here close out the access
for that queen maybe but
how do you do that cgm could then
maneuver
and try to bring the queen okay
yeah on and opening up the f file
but you might open up too much here
maybe
queen takes uh queen takes f2 king
to h1 and then the c6 pawn
is a little bit weak and it works on the
d file so you always have to worry about
a
queen invasion or a rook invasion on the
seventh rank
uh it's just this is tough wow
yeah this has been a back and forth game
for sure
um whereas game one was really more
about time this is
more about plans
okay and he decides to take and now
we're gonna
you're saying well maybe see queen takes
f2 check
king moves and now
and now it's dicey now sagem might feel
the heat
right as my uh
yeah maybe maybe rook takes us maybe
slightly better
but as my ukrainian coach would say now
what do
shield anvil in the chat saying they're
both just tapping jab
sounds about right sounds all right yeah
okay i'm really excited to see the
finish here
all right uh queen trade
green trade's happening uh it's gone
i mean they have a pawn right if you're
up a pawn you trade down pieces
and then you have more pawns in your
opponent and your bishop gets active
this is not a mistake this is this is
some strong chance but we have to
be careful here because the rook is
probably going to move and then if
both rooks get to the same frank
i don't know it looks it looks dangerous
it looks really dangerous with that
bishop on b3
kind of barreling and looking down at g1
any rook check on this square would be
mate yeah but say james got to figure
out how to get these two rooks in order
and that
is not what you want anyway but i don't
really want it
oh i'm so dumb actually it's not that
bad right it could be worse
it could be worse positive attitude um
always important when you're losing
that was a big mistake i think it has to
go
it has to go here probably right
but i don't have anything to defend that
yeah
it won't that that's the classy move
right there uh
okay
yeah this one came to play here we're
he has to be careful of f3 he has to be
very careful i hope he sees it
i hope he sees it hopefully sees that
this move here
is kind of dangerous because you can't
take it
and you've got a rook backing it up for
a potential push
right exactly exactly and the king
cannot go to
g2 if that happens right
so this is business the loss of his rook
combined with
all of this available free space for for
e sam's rook on
rooks on the board is this might be what
does it
is there something with rook takes g2
check
there might be there might be there's a
lot of ways to finish this game i think
i think uh has a lot of time he needs to
send it now this is the time where he
needs to kind of stop
i i would even consider some moves like
um and he pushes yeah
yeah has to push you
if the pawn were on h4 like his
h7 were on h4 i would say yes or if it
were on each
h5 yeah
i don't know maybe he saves it maybe he
saves it to put a little bit of
put a little bit of english on it as i
like to say
what is esam thinking right now yeah
let's go he seems like he's pretty happy
with the state of things
but i thought about it but i thought
about it chad just know it says down
here i don't know if you can see it
[Music]
sure okay probably not so dangerous
put the rook on f2 and go for me maybe
or just take the free row
yep there's that pretty sure there was a
much simpler mate that i could have done
but
[Music]
the bishop defending is
no still any danger here with a lot of a
lot of pieces that can still make moves
uh for white you got a bishop you got a
bunch of pawns
uh he seems got this in the bag it looks
like
yeah and here very
clean way to win is just to uh
play just rookie okay you can win the
bishop
but uh here we are going for maid and
there's
all this free stuff yeah
yeah me who cares about me when we can
win a free bishop right
wow just taking the free stuff who cares
about me yeah yeah
yeah just take everything and maybe
sagem is saying you know
just take everything and let me see if i
could get some kind of stalemate
that would be epic right
but i don't know let's see i think
now he's got this rook comes over wait
wait
we saw this before wait
uh unfortunately he has a pawn that can
move to g5
yeah this should be okay yeah
and there we go it's done
esam has wrapped this one up 2-0 match
over e sam takes it home
with a weird free stream
but i got like i got the one lead damn
one mistake
no blunders e sam
kind of nice with it he's loving it
he's put it he's put it in the books
it's over he sam defeats ajam
in round one of tournament r2 that is
the conclusion of our match but not the
conclusion
of our broadcast because when we come
back we're going to interview
say jamini sam so wow jt a
pretty strong performance from esam and
uh it makes me wonder
with four other competitors yet to be
seen with uh
sea dog and giga who we know also can be
very strong
this is gonna be a cool winter's bracket
with esam up there what do you think
it's gonna be insane i can't wait for
tomorrow i mean
we still haven't finished today we have
to see what they're saying but i can't
wait for tomorrow i can't wait for next
week
i think every day is going to be
action-packed and there's going to be a
surprise every single day so
make sure you don't miss that and with
that we'll be right back with the
players so stay tuned don't go anywhere
and
we'll see you in just a few minutes
[Music]
so
on
[Music]
and we're back and we're here with the
players say jim and esam
wow that was great chess uh sagem
obviously
the match didn't go your way but uh
i did have a question for you um just
basically like what was
it like facing e sam in those two games
and what were some of the takeaways that
you feel i mean obviously we watched you
analyze
actually that first game during the
break and and we heard some of your
plans about taking those
thoughts into the second game and yeah
just kind of expand on
what that experience was like uh
yeah i mean for me right like i'm super
new right and
i know that he has much more experience
than me so
basically i went in with like the
thought process of okay
i'm gonna try and uh learn as much as i
can
over like whatever games happen because
it's not like i expect to you know go in
and crush but if i can just learn some
things then maybe it'll help
like you know in whatever comes up in
the next game or whatever and i think my
decision making over the games got
much better so i was pretty happy with
how i played them both
yeah and jt i mean you and i kind of
talked about that right we made the
observation in that second game
that the the the separation uh
on the clock was uh was very reduced
right
it was obvious that sageman was talking
about wanting to uh
make some faster moves and i think we
saw that uh esam
um what was that like for you to see
that change in say jam in the second
game
um so i definitely noticed that uh i
literally mentioned it in my stream i
was just like huh sage was playing a lot
faster
because at some point in the first game
it was like eight and a half minutes to
like two and a half grand granted i play
fast to a fault so i kind of anticipate
that i'm going to be ahead on time
against like
everybody granted i haven't studied the
other players terribly much yet
uh but i noticed he was playing fashion
i was like okay this is good but
uh i had the mindset of like okay well
like the opposite side of stage i'm like
i'm more experienced so if i just
don't mess up i should find the
opportunities whether it's even
like we're even all the way to endgame i
get a single pawn and then convert stuff
like that
uh but he honestly other than like i
think in the
uh second game it was pretty even
until you just gave up your rook so like
you were playing that very well like you
were playing a very tight game you
always were threatening
on what was it uh h severed f7
the like bishop and queen so like the
entire time was just like okay
like i just had to keep reminding myself
like don't move that rook or i'm going
to lose immediately
like there were a couple times when i
was like i'm gonna move my brook to
challenge the other no
and then i just like let go um
so you set up a lot of traps and then
the blunder happened and i was like oh
okay from this point i
should win and jt i mean you and i were
really impressed with both games but
maybe especially that second game
where uh you know the chat kind of
talked about a little bit more
jabbing chess
yeah they were saying that you were like
putting out jabs and jabs and jabs um
but
if i can comment uh on that like the
second game
before the blunder was almost played
perfectly like you should be
say jam and izan both you should be
extremely
happy with the way you played like it
was like me watching somebody who's an
expert or master play
like i want to say that you you guys
almost had no mistakes you
both thought logically um this is
something that i would see
probably in the 1800s 2000 rated pool
and i was so impressed i was
what was it going back like thank you
you guys saw the f5 break you guys saw
doubling the rooks you saw you know
moving the pieces around
nice c5 trying to get your the
bishop pair away and then bishop
captures c5 because the bishop is not
doing so much like
everything you guys just saw everything
right and it was it was just awesome to
see
good chess being played and
congratulations to you both
and if you say damn i know you're going
to the redemption mark if
you keep playing like that
they're in trouble well my thought
process is like i'm like super
green right so i've only been playing
since like the start of this week and my
thought is like okay
what if i can make it to like the second
week right i was like i think my chances
are way higher i just have to somehow
not get eliminated
that's between and then next week i have
a good chance right but like if i
if i get smoked now then i'm like oh
well good games i tried
well kiss deal blunder stalemates
against you so you should be fine
i play someone else actually oh wait no
yeah you're wrong part of reckon sorry
sorry sorry
yeah hold on a second so wait wait wait
wait wait wait
starting to sound sage i am like you may
be taking notes from ludwig
in pogchamps like you know what i'll
throw for content on that first one and
then i'll get into the
the other bracket and i'll clean up is
that what's going on here it's
it's literally zero throw i'm just like
my thought process
is like i see where i started and like
where i am now and i'm just like okay if
i
can just somehow survive like i have a
chance to do
better and then like you know make it
further but yeah i mean it's hard i
think everybody is like uh
you know at the point where you know
we're all really interested in trying to
learn and my thought process is even if
i play the worst chess of my life and i
lose both like you know sets immediately
i'm like really excited either way
because i've always wanted an excuse to
learn chess
and i never really had one you know it
was like oh yeah i guess i could learn
chess but if i do i want to get like
really interested in it
so it's like a good time now to just be
like okay i should probably sit down and
actually play some chess so even if i
get smoked i'm pretty happy that i
learned it either way
the fact they've only been playing for a
week and like i analyzed the second game
as well and
you other than like the big blunder like
you as they said you basically played
perfect
and i see more mistakes against the
people that i play against in like quick
play
that are like 1100 1150 like you played
that
super well it's why i think i'm so
behind on time because like
my oh i have like no plan in the opening
i make like three moves and i'm like
okay
i don't know what's happening so i have
to like sit and think about the whole
entire board so in the second game i try
to play faster and then i blundered
because of it but
i was just happier i played quicker well
we're actually
going to see both of you again on sunday
this weekend
and you will each play the winner and
the loser respectively e sam
and c jam of uh the match between sea
dog
and gigguk and esam i want to ask you um
do you feel like one player strikes a
little bit more fear maybe in you than
another or
are you kind of like worried both ways
not worried both ways
i'm a bit worried as far as i remember i
could be misremembering but i think
both of them are over a thousand rating
and i know
i think this was a tournament arcade or
it was a different chess tournament in
which case i apologize
giggit won the first one yep so
he's the reigning champ so i would be a
little bit more scared of him
uh but i mean if i feel like if i play
if i just
slow down and play i'm way better than
my rating shows
and if i'm better than my rating shows
then that means i'm the best player
here in terms of just like conceptual
i'm not saying i'm better than them i'm
not saying i'm going to win
but like that's my mindset which is like
if i just play well
i will beat everyone which is kind of
how i think of when i go into
tournaments like
smash tournaments i'm just like if i
just play well i'll just win the
tournament and then the times i
have thought that and executed i won the
tournament or you know lost to the other
best players in the world in which case
whoa sorry
but i'd say what do you feel about
uh also having to face either gig or
sea dog in your next match uh yeah i'm
excited for it either way i mean no
matter who
i play my strategy is the same tonight
i'm gonna play some chats tomorrow i'll
play some chess and then sunday
like you know i'll show up and play and
if i do well
hell yeah if i do bad you know i'll
watch the rest of the tournament and
i'll be cool with it so i'm you know i'm
not too bothered either way
uh i'm just really interested to see the
matches tomorrow because
the the kids the ollie match especially
was just it was too much for my
like insane yeah it was so sick so i'm
like excited to watch no matter what
awesome and jt i'll i'll let you have
the last question here before we
uh say goodbye to the players
um when's marvel
no um i um i
i'm just super proud of you guys and if
i don't really have a question but i
would say focus a lot on doing tactics
that's what's really going to set you
guys apart
because people are going to make
mistakes and you want to be able to have
the tools to capitalize on
those mistakes so make sure you're doing
that and prepare for the next one
pulsars puzzles are lit i'm at like 1900
in puzzles they're super fun
puzzles are yeah yeah well guys that was
an awesome match
uh quality chess from both of you and uh
we're excited to see you both back here
on sunday
uh good luck in your preparation for
your next match and um
we'll see you then yeah
later gamers there you have it guys
e sam and say jam moving on to
uh different sides of the bracket but uh
there's still chances for them to maybe
even see each other again
and that's kind of what this redemption
arc is all about somebody
who did not win their first round
today and or tomorrow will make it all
the way back
to the grand final to play
somebody for the championships so
jt maybe looking ahead at tomorrow we've
got tech tone
rustage and then sea dog gig
do you want to make predictions uh which
matchup between the two are you most
excited about
like like the floor is yours what is
tomorrow going to be like
i i'm expecting
a really good match um against score
like i i think we're going to get
a crazy match with teen sea dog and
antigua
and i don't want to call
numbers but i want to draw on that one
as well
i think that would be hilarious um
and russell versus sexton i mean
jackie's just a little charismatic that
you have to
root for him if you don't you're you're
like a villain
so as much as i like rustage i
you know i feel like i'm a bit biased or
sucky
i i gotta say i'm the other way i think
that rustage is stronger
than even he may believe and uh i i you
know we've seen what we've seen from him
in tournament arc one
but uh but this is different i mean
rustage has experience
in a tournament setting and tech tone
doesn't so that may be another thing
that uh could seal the deal for restage
and obviously
sea dog and gigging with the history of
tournament arc one
and that draw in uh in the final
that sealed the deal for giga i know
there is so much build up here
over a year of people wanting to see
a rematch between these two players
in a tournament and now we're gonna have
it and uh with that
we're gonna say good night to everybody
here but
not if you don't want it to be because
my man right here jt
is going to stream and uh we're going to
send the raid his way
uh he'll do a little bit of tournament
arc wrap up and maybe some other fun
stuff
but you're not going to know if you
don't stick around for that raid if
you're on twitch so
make sure you stay for that jt uh this
has been
a probably this has been a perfect first
day
in my opinion for what stands to be an
awesome event for tournament r2 like
what what what do you think going into
the rest of this like have we set an
awesome tone or what
i think it was more you than me and um
keep carrying the show thank you so much
no no it was the players the players
actually have done all the hard work you
and i have just sat here and gotten to
enjoy it with everybody
like oh man yeah actually right
well with that said we're gonna say
goodbye to everybody for tonight and we
will see you all back here tomorrow
at 5 p.m pacific tech tone b rustage
sea dog v gigguk and all of the other
remaining shows after that so
good night everybody stick around for
the raid with jt and uh
thank you so much for watching uh we'll
see you tomorrow
you